foreign
looks like we have a lot of people still
shoveling
I don't want to delay us too much
because we have some very special guests
today to see us
um but I did want to at some point today
we will go over the kind of the schedule
that's re-emerging after we had to
cancel on Monday
so without further Ado if we're ready I
would like to welcome up uh Joseph
Malika and Tina Demers from The Liquor
Commission welcome
so today just so you know folks the the
word uh listening to agencies to hear
about their unrestricted well primarily
their unrestricted Revenue
um this is not exactly uh estimates yet
but more of a high level overview of
what they do and what kind of funds they
receive
thank you madam chair good morning
morning members of the committee my name
is Joseph Malik I'm the chairman of the
New Hampshire Liquor Commission and with
me is our CFO Tina Demers
you have a handout in front of you that
we've provided we'll go through it
quickly and then if there's any
questions we'll be happy to answer so on
page two you'll see the 17 control state
jurisdictions that are in the United
States after prohibition the federal
government allowed the states to decide
whether or not they would be controller
open and those are the states that
decided to be control States on page
three you'll see our retail outlet
locations
nine of which are state-owned and you
can see the square footage and 59 which
are leased 27 of those outlets now have
curbside pickup that we initiated during
the pandemic in September of 2020 and
we've done 7.6 million dollars in sales
curbside since that time
on page four you'll see the three-tier
system as it's currently presented we in
the state of New Hampshire uh take part
in two parts of the tier where the
wholesaler to
on-premise and off-premise which are a
grocery and restaurant and we do the
retailing obviously in our retail
outlets
on page five you'll see uh what the
nebca the national Alcohol Beverage
Control Association deems the values of
the three-tier system I won't run
through those but they're there for you
to peruse
on page six uh you'll see our
competition how it's come about in 2011
governor Patrick signed a bill to allow
people to have additional liquor
licenses in New Hampshire you can see
our competition in New Hampshire on page
six on page seven you'll notice the
Total Wine and More is our biggest
competition in New Hampshire they were
not in New Hampshire uh I'm sorry they
weren't in Massachusetts until 2014
they're the largest independent liquor
and wine retailer in the United States
they have 245 stores in 27 States they
have 11 000 employees and they have 10
stores in New England and you know some
people say well we do business in New
Hampshire well we do and we do we do we
do a good job of doing business in New
Hampshire but 50 percent of our business
comes from outside of the state so
that's one thing that we always need to
remember as we go through our business
needs
more more competition on the way in New
Hampshire Market Basket is open liquor
stores they've held liquor licenses for
years in Massachusetts and in Maine so
they're opening liquor stores in
Massachusetts now they're opening four
this year they have a couple open
already Costco's opening two more in
Massachusetts and BJ's is opening
another one as well
just bringing that to you
because of so much of our business comes
from outside of the state
so on page eight the introduction
The Liquor Commission is self-funded
it's a separate fund outside of the
general fund and no general fund
Appropriations are used to maintain or
operate our business
on page nine the statute that guides The
Liquor Commission is 176 colon 3 and the
guidelines there
on page 10 you'll see the orgas
organizational structure of the Liquor
Commission and the full and part-time
classified and unclassified employees
that run thereof
and on page 11 the divisions Office of
the commission division of enforcement
division of administration and the
division of Market marketing and
Merchandising
we've asked for 24 new positions in the
budget this year uh in the stores in the
outlets we've run down employees for a
number of years and it's time to bolster
those store employees with some
additional help
and I'll turn it over to teen at this
point
good morning
page 12 is just a listing of the
state-owned stores that were identified
earlier so I will start with page 13
which is our net profit history the
first chart is the growth since the
commission started in 1935 and you'll
see that the commission has generated
4.3 billion in net profit in our 88
years
the other chart is just a 10-year of our
annual net profit from FY 13 to FY 22 so
that you can see the historical Trend
and then on the next slides I will
further Break Down The Five-Year
so on page 14 our revenue is broken down
into three main Revenue categories and
on slide 15 there's a chart that shows
the five-year history
first you have beer tax and permits
which is 30 cents a gallon sold or
transferred for retail sales or to the
public from authorized licensees
then you have like liquor and wine
Revenue the sale of wine spirits and
accessories through our Outlets
warehouses to retail customers
on-premise customers which are
restaurants in lounges and off-premise
licensees such as grocery stores and
convenience stores
and then our the revenue is primarily
from licensing fees which is about 3.6
million and it also includes direct
shipping permits of about 1.6 million
and then Lottery and other miscellaneous
Revenue
so you can see that we had large growth
in FY 21 and in FY 22 we were down 11
million but you'll see that in FY 22 we
still had significant growth over the FY
20 pre-pandemic of about 15 million
foreign
so slide 16
is a five-year history of our revenue
and expenses and the line in the middle
is our actual net revenue which is
transferred annually
so it goes from 157.4 million in FY 18
and to
166.1 million in FY 22.
and you'll uh can note that our Revenue
our expense to revenue transfer has I
mean ratio has been consistent around 30
percent
on slide 17. this is a graph of the
five-year transfer history and estimates
for FY 23 to 25. there are two rsas that
govern our Revenue transfers prior to
the transfer to the general fund the two
rsas are listed on the bottom of the
next page the first transfer requirement
under RSA
17616 is calculated into our Revenue
plan since it's five percent of our
previous year's gross profit which is
the first item listed in the bar chart
in the green
and then it starts at 6.8 million in FY
18 and is estimated to be around 11
million in FY 2425
then there is the RSA 126 AAA colon 3
and this is not in our Revenue plan
because it's the additional funds that
are requested by HHS for the granite
advantage and you can see this is as the
next item in the bar chart for FY 22 23
21 22 and 23 and it's 8.2 8.7 and 7.2
million
then the next item in the chart is beer
tax which is consistent around 13
million and then in the blue is the last
item which is the remaining net revenue
from liquor operations
okay
so on page 18
this lays out the transfers that I
mentioned starting with the total
revenue and then the five percent
transferred to the alcohol abuse and
prevention fund
and that um that's included in our plan
and then we show this so that you can
see that number compared to our plan
which are rows three and four
then there's the additional transfer to
HHS for the final liquor transfer to the
general fund and this is followed then
by the beer tax and then you have the
total transfer to the general fund
excuse me so our estimates for FY 23 24
and 25 are what we've provided in our
budget request and we're on target this
year for our plan which we think is
notable in this ever-changing business
environment and unpredictable National
economy especially since the current
plan was created two years ago
uh so we have our FY 24 liquor estimates
which is 139.5 million and our fy25 is
140.1 million with our beer tax flat at
about 13.2 million
on page 19 we have the breakdown for our
FY 22 sales by customer type and
category so the categories are spirits
wine and accessories and accessories are
the items sold in the stores such as
mixers corkscrews items like that
so you can see that the retail Spirits
are 383 million or 50 of our business
the retail wine is 173 million or 22.6
percent of our business and in total
retail accounts for about 72.7 of our
business and the pie charts just show
you the breakdown in the spirits and
wines by the customer type
on Slide 20. the sales for our top 15
Outlet locations in FY 22 was 306
million and they account for 51 of our
Outlet sales
slide 21 uh agency stores there are
three licensed agency stores that sell
spheres and wine one was established in
2003 and two in 2005. we have two in the
North country and one in the southern
part of the state and you'll notice that
the arrow location has no sales in FY 22
and that's because they are in the
process of rebuilding because they had a
fire
um
excuse me the next slide so these are
Outlet changes since uh 2012 we've
relocated renovated or constructed 40
new locations in more than 35
communities this year we've opened new
outlet locations in ringed Concord and
Manchester and we're in the process of
new stores in Nashua and Derry
so on page 23 you'll see our ringed
location which opened in May of 2020 I
mean 2022 I went from a little over 5000
square feet to a little over ten
thousand square feet and in FY 23 the
sales were 3.5 million which is an
increase of 22 percent
the next location is Concord exit 17
which opened in August of 2022. it was 4
000 square feet and is moved to uh over
13 000 square feet the sales in FY 23 so
far are 3.1 million and that's an
increase of 3.3 percent
and then the last Outlet was the
Manchester Gold Street location which
opened in September of 2022 this is a
little under 13 000 square feet they've
done 2.9 Million for fiscal year 23.
and at this point I will turn it back
over to the chairman okay thank you Tina
so members of the committee on page 26
you'll see hb2 Liquor Commission request
in 2011 I proposed uh incentive program
with then Governor Lynch it was put in
House Bill 2 when we put it through
we've never we've never used it and this
year we put three three or four
different proposals in front of the
governor there was one in particular
that he liked and he has approved for us
to put in House Bill 2 and you'll see
the language on page 27 and this is this
has been approved obviously in 2011 the
governor is in support of it and what
we're trying to do now is to be able to
unfund the incentive program through the
additional profits that the Liquor
Commission will make so that it'll be
additional incentive for our employees
our full-time employees and part-time
employees in the retail locations only
so the people that are out in the stores
that are grossly underpaid quite frankly
at 12.38 an hour to start uh need some
additional income and this is our way to
get it to them
so on page 28 just some quick marketing
goals I won't you know bore you with the
details but we do our best to bring the
best products and value to our customers
through positive shopping experience we
engage our customers with online and in
Outlet in Outlet engagement we support
our New Hampshire businesses and we
position uh the nhlc Best in Class
through a number of initiatives web
initiatives e-commerce we have 125 000
visitors a month to our website again
they're the stats for the the in-store
pickup and the curbside delivery again
7.6 million dollars and additional sales
since 2020.
on page 30 just some of the customer
engagement we bring a lot of
celebrities and people in through our
marketing and we get them involved in
our business and our customers really
enjoy it our monthly sales obviously
that not only consumers can take
advantage of but licensees can take
advantage of as well
and on page 32 some social and emailing
just uh just some points of interest
Instagram we have 67 plus 100 followers
Facebook we get about 150 likes we've
had about 116 000 engagements on Twitter
uh we have 7 500 followers and it's good
to see that those engagements are up
over year over year and we've we've
gained close to 25
000 subscribers in our email marketing
so that's an important piece to us
everything we do everything that we're
out there trying to push is we Garner
those emails and that gives us
additional uh face time with those
consumers
you can see some of the brand building
campaigns on page 33 a keep it local
campaign where we take the local
wineries and distilleries and we give
consumers a discount on those products
every day
hmm
on page 34 just some quick Google
reviews uh from July 1st 2021 to June
30th 2022
00 Google reviews 90 91 of which are
four and five ratings so that's
important for us that in the eyes of the
consumers that are actually here in our
stores we're doing a good job and on
page 35 we Prof we we partner with our
Brokers and suppliers uh to bring these
charitable contributions to the state
and since 2015 we've raised 3.5 million
dollars for non-profit organizations
across the state and those are just a
few that we've done
on page 36 and 37 are just some of the
some of the awards and some of the
accolades that the Liquor Commission has
um
been given in the last 10 years and uh
we appreciate that our customers like
what we do and their uh
willing to respond to
it by coming to our stores and raising
our sales so we'd be happy to answer any
questions
wow that was impressive that was really
concise there's a lot of information
that we just so you know at least half
of us are freshmen in this room so we
might have to slow it back down and go
back to one particular page that I think
we're interested in
um I should mention we're not talking
about a bill but I am a liquor licensee
and I can tell you the Liquor Commission
does an amazing job so what are
questions uh over here representative
I had maybe a dozen but I'll re refrain
and ask one or two yeah yeah the first
question I had is why the dip in FY 22
was post covid so what what do you think
caused the dip
from 2021
it's because we had such significant
growth in FY 21 from the pandemic people
being at home our retail sales were
through the roof we had a lot of people
that were moving into the state so we
had significant growth in that year so
you'll see that the actual FY 22 is
still a significant growth over fy20
which was pre-pandemic
representative fellows thank you
um I have a question about you at the
beginning you said that you kind of
operate separate from the general fund
and if that's the case does that mean
that the new liquor stores that you're
building
did not come out of the word they're
charged to the Liquor Commission and not
to the general fund they're not part of
administrative Services properties
that's correct
thank you
representative Schamberg
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question and being here today
uh mostly a policy question are you by
uh
state statute
I have a set rate you charge on liquor
or beers compared to our neighbors
Massachusetts
Maine and Vermont well we do have a
guideline that is posted something that
we our markup percentage is posted so
yes my state statute it's not a St I
don't believe it's statute no okay I'll
have a follow-up when we get around to
me again okay sounds good representative
Southworth
thank you for taking my question on the
chart on page 17 is it possible that the
contribution to Granite Advantage will
continue
more than likely yes yes so and so that
should be considered uh for um 24 and
25.
right but we don't include it yes I
understand because we don't know how
much they're going to request okay thank
you thank you
okay uh representative Ames did you have
a question no representative almi
on
your percentage uh We've you've fighting
for years now against total marketing on
and
on to keep the message our Massachusetts
share on do you what has happened on
since the pandemic in terms of of the
percentage of customers that are coming
from south of us
well or all around us well during the
pandemic obviously there was a lot less
customers coming across the border we
followed the toll counts and the door
counts in our stores and at the highway
so there was a lot less consumers coming
in from out of state at that point total
is uh you know total is the largest
privately owned Wine and Spirits
retailer in the United States there if
you want to compete with them you have
to run like a business if you don't run
like a business you don't compete with
them that's you know it's owned by Two
Brothers one of them happens to be a
congressman in the sixth district in
Maryland and they've owned the business
uh since the 80s they started with one
business their big private label
retailer that's something that the
Liquor Commission does not do we sell
brand we sell brand name products they
do not
representative jinnegan
thank you madam chair so um I want to
focus again on this competition
um you mentioned that Total Wine is
building more stores and mass and so
forth
um
what is it that's given us the
competitive advantage in the past is it
is it price and it and is so even if
they build more stores do we still have
that advantage or what is it that
what does that kind of lie well I think
were equal to or less with them on price
every day
what we don't do is bait and switch
consumers they do it constantly it's
part of their marketing scheme they'll
advertise a lower price get you in they
won't either they won't have the product
or they won't have enough of it when
people come to New Hampshire to buy
most of the time they buy in bulk our
business has always been built on that
bulk buy we don't want people the per
the consumer that comes in and buys one
bottle and leaves is an important
consumer but the consumer that drives
the business is the is the person that
picks up two or three or four cases
recognizing the value I'm from New York
it's twenty dollars a bottle less here
I'm going to buy it here and take it
home with me that's where that's where
we beat total every day of the week as
well as our selection when you go into
their stores they do not have the
selection that we have they do not have
the skew counts that they have that we
have they also carry beer which we don't
we don't carry they carry party goods
and they have humidors in the store as
well so they're a little more uh gross
reminded in that aspect we're we're more
of a wine and spirits Outlet we do have
those some of those sundry items and
they are important to our business but
we don't rely on them as uh for
additional sales
okay we'll keep going around the room
anyone over on this side representative
Malloy
thank you thank you for telling me my
question uh this isn't a revenue or
expense question this is about emails
how do you capture email addresses when
we when we run up a program part of the
entry to the program is giving us your
email address so anything that we do
whether it's in store with consumers in
a tasting we ask people to give us their
email address if it's if it's someone
wants to enter a contest that we run or
they want more information about a
product we ask them to give us their
email it's total totally voluntary
thank you very much thank you
did you have a question yes go ahead
thank you madam chair um regarding out
of state revenue you know a few words to
be a member of like a wine of the month
club or something how's that Revenue
handled
all the the revenue that comes in
through Direct ship is is revenue that's
included in the reports that Tina gave
you so if you belong to uh
New York Times Wine of the month club
and it comes and you buy through through
them it goes through our Direct ship
program so that's all funneled through
the revenues that Tina is showing you
and that's handled by our enforcement
division
thank you you're welcome
now all the questions on this side of
the room right now okay good we'll move
back around yes representative Schamberg
thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my follow-up
question now
as representative almi mentioned about
the percentage of customers how you try
to keep them in there
does this flexibility
of not being directed by a state statute
on price give you the ability to counter
the these changes that are on our
neighbors absolutely it does
uh
follow up
and and we wouldn't be yes I would we
wouldn't be really business-minded if we
weren't constantly looking at that and
doing it every day I mean part of part
of what I do on a daily basis is find
out what other people are doing
okay follow up Madam chair final
follow-up final follow-up is on a
different
one is uh when you uh uh construct or
build
uh in a community uh what was your
percentage of overrun costs with
construction
do you have any idea of that or can you
get back to me we I we can get back to
you but what I'd like to explain one of
the things I'd like to just quickly say
when you see us build as you you saw the
broke down the breakdown of stores that
we own versus what we what we release
our landlords we are in a pattern now
with our landlords where we add into the
square footage for the first 10 years of
the lease so we will add in an
additional two to five dollars per
square foot the landlords actually are
paying The Upfront cost for us to build
those stores and we are paying for it
over the first 10 years of the lease and
an additional four to five dollars a
square foot so our costs are de minimis
in building these stores
representative Ames
this is a question about the employee
incentive payments and uh I'm wondering
if you could back up from that request
to what's the situation that that you're
facing in terms of recruiting and
retaining employees that leads to this
request and uh and how are you doing
generally in terms of Staff in your
stores
uh
I don't think abysmal would cover it
I I think we're we're in a very tough
situation as are all retailers and all
employers but unfortunately the state
system only allows us to pay employees
what the state system allows us to pay
one of and one of the other requests we
had asked for some additional uh
flexibility in that
12.38 I drove by the McDonald's in
Claremont yesterday just as an example
eighteen dollars an hour up on the
Marquee work today get paid tomorrow
free meal with every shift uh 2500 to 5
000 in uh incentive for employment
things that we just don't do and all
cons all
employers are recognizing that you have
to do more one of the things that we do
very poorly unfortunately for our
employees is the ability to pay them
what they deserve I'm not asking for
anything more than what the average is
but we need to be able to pay our
employees more
follow up and keep in mind folks that
this will all go to finance too and
it'll be part of the budget
deliberations okay on that part okay
yeah I think you mentioned uh that this
isn't the only initiative that you've
thought of and you've put forward as a
possible
option for the Liquor Commission to deal
with this problem is it possible you
could share those other requests
absolutely we'd be happy to do that okay
thank you
representative almie
thank you could you explain to us what
the state system is that is setting our
employee rates at so low that we can't
compete with anyone on anything
well that's done through admin Services
that's not that's not something that the
Liquor Commission does yeah it's it's
somewhere in that admin service that's
correct and that's a state it's a state
pay scale that we have to follow when we
hire our employees yes
okay um moving right along
representative did you have a question
yeah
um
when you add new stores now whoever you
do it is that increasing sales or just
convenience is it raising your cost
without resulting in sales
oh it's clearly raising the sales and
clearly it's raising the bottom line as
well obviously when we do these stores
we're thinking of 25 years from now one
of the things that the Liquor Commission
wasn't really good at was thinking about
what's going to happen 10 years from now
15 years from now 20 years from now if
you're going to be in the alcohol
beverage retail business you have to
give consumers an inviting opportunity
to come into your stores and Shop
products that they've never seen before
our Outlet price Buster program is one
of those
opportunities as well as many others but
if we don't have the size and the
selection you can see we have less
stores than we had 10 years ago but we
have 245
000 Square more square feet of retail so
we've gotten away from those dog leg
stores in the corners of Plaza that were
completely uninviting and gone to this
look and feel that consumers now
recognize not only from drive you know
driving down the highway but wrecking
nice from our advertising and marketing
as well
representative Malloy thank you thank
you for taking my question this is a tag
on to the previous question I I think
what I'm looking what I want to ask you
is with all that work you're doing in
the new stores and all that where is
that Peak and I know it's almost
impossible to answer but where when will
we top out
that revenue from liquor that's
uh again I don't know that I expect an
answer here but that's what I'm looking
at thank you well I can I can tell you
that as as long as the state continues
to grow and the state Contin which which
it has obviously especially in the North
country and we continue to be inviting
to people to come here we're a tourist
State and we have to we have it's a
whole gamut of things that bring people
here to the state not obviously we
benefit from it from our general fund
revenues from The Liquor Commission but
we have to make sure that we watch all
those things that bring people here to
the state snowmobiling four-wheeling
skiing hiking restaurants
you know the water sports Etc all that
is an important piece of what we do and
I think we're probably five to seven
years away from seeing any type of peak
with sales especially given the
availability to do Direct ship starting
in New Hampshire when our next gen our
new POS system launches and then to go
out of state as well
there's a number of states that allow
that to happen 13 I believe in total at
this point thank you very much for that
perspective it's very helpful thank you
thank you representative
representative divorce thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question maybe I missed it but in here
is there a budget estimate for the
incentives for these uh individual
employees that you want to
keep or retain or
it's based on sales growth so it depends
they'll get uh 10 of the growth and at
this point
um
it could be anywhere from you know half
a million to a couple of million okay
thank you and follow question please
uh did I understand you folks do
sampling in the stores or
we do oh they do okay and did you bring
samples with you
thank you madam chair wonderful
presentation thank you so much for
making it so concise and so beautiful
and we may see you again soon certainly
okay great thank you we are members of
the committee thank you
thank you
okay well now welcome up the insurance
department we have Christopher nicopolis
Christy rice and Amy duhane and for the
record even though we don't have a bill
I buy a lot of insurance welcome
chairman and uh thank you for
having us uh next year let's schedule me
before uh something interesting Like
Liquor because it's pretty pretty hard
to compete uh with insurance after
hearing all that exciting stuff about uh
tastings and and whatnot
um my name is Chris nicolopos I'm the
Commissioner of Insurance I'm joined uh
here at the table by Amy duhame who's
our chief tax officer and behind us
we've got assistant commissioner rice uh
Jim young and Jen Goodwin who are part
of our tax team
um I know that about half of this
committee is new and so I'm going to
take three or four minutes to talk about
the background of the insurance
department what our mission and goals
are and then uh at about five slide six
I'll I'll uh tap Amy here and she'll
talk to you about our current revenue
and our projected Revenue going forward
the mission in New Hampshire insurance
department is to promote the public good
by ensuring the existence of safe and
competitive Insurance Marketplace and
just about everything we do is directed
at that consumer protect consumer
protection goal a New Hampshire
insurance department has a unique a
distinction we were the first state
insurance department established in the
United States we were established in
1851 and for an industry that's almost
entirely State regulated that shows the
foresight that the state of New
Hampshire had
our laws are governed and found between
RSA 400 and 420q
and we're we're charged with the
enforcement of all state regulated
Insurance here in the state that takes
many forms I think
um some interesting stats there are
almost 1300 insurance companies licensed
to do business in the state of New
Hampshire
on top of that there are nearly two
hundred thousand uh we're on page four
now nearly 200 000 Insurance licensees
and those are made up of Insurance
Producers and insurance adjusters now
I'll be the first to admit that 200 000
licensees for 1.3 million people is too
many we don't need that many licensees
but what the pandemic showed us was
National Insurance companies that have
large stats that were instantly remote
chose to license all of their producers
and all of their Adjusters in any place
that they could easily do it just in
case those people happen to work with
New Hampshire consumers and so we saw
just a meteoric rise in the number of
licensees license here in the state we
do not believe that that's sustainable
or or necessary you don't need a
licensee for every seven people
um I and so furthering our mission of uh
protecting the public there are a lot of
things we do with insurance companies to
make sure that they are able to to meet
their obligations to our our citizens
and so the first thing we do is
financial review of the companies we
make sure that their balance sheets are
accurate that they have adequate liquid
funds that they're investing them
appropriately that they're reporting
them appropriately and we do that with
with 50 other insurance commissions
around the nation to make sure these
insurance companies are fairly
representing their financial
um uh of standing
we then look for each of the 1300
companies for every product they sell
they're required to have those forms
approved by somebody in our department
and that means that big policy you get
at the end of every year that no one
ever reads until there's a loss we have
a team of people three people uh in in
one side of our house and and four in
the other who read every single line of
every single potential policy for New
Hampshire to make sure it complies with
our state law with federal laws is
applicable but also protects consumers
rights and uh and complies with how we
expect them to handle claims
we have another group of people who look
at Insurance assumptions and actual
analysis and so what those people are
looking for is to ensure that a company
is picking a premium that adequately
represents the risk they're taking and
that's a not too high not too low
analysis we don't want a company
charging a premium that that provides
them excess profits above what risk
they're taking and we also want to
protect companies and protect our
consumers from companies who try to buy
market share by pricing their product
below what they need to pay claims
because that's not sustainable
and so our actuaries do an analysis and
and look at assumptions made by these
companies we're fortunate New Hampshire
to have a super competitive Marketplace
almost all of our markets are
competitive and that's in part because
we take the live free to die approach to
regulating businesses we allow them to
to do to do business
but our number one objective of the
insurance department notwithstand the
fact that Amy's sitting here is
protecting consumers at our consumer
services division we have seven staff
members that all they do is manage
consumer questions inquiries or
complaints that manifests itself in
about 5 000 individual touches to our
department a year many of those most of
those are simple it's a consumer who
doesn't understand an EOB or an
explanation of benefit from their health
carrier or they don't understand what
actual cash value means or they don't
understand how a company is going to
Value their total loss car or how long
they have rental car insurance for and
so most of those about 85 percent of
those inquiries were able to handle
pretty quickly get people to the right
information show them in their policy
where something is or where something's
not
um but the remaining 15 or 750 turn into
consumer we consider consumer complaints
those are complaints that we investigate
at our uh at our office to ensure that
the insurance company is complying with
our law that they're treating the
consumers fairly that they're paying
claims as they're required and they're
doing it in a quick and orderly fashion
of those 750 after a full analysis about
half of them are found to be not
violations of law they're just that's
that's how the policies are written but
we're able to explain to Consumers why
and how something's happening and about
half of them we find that the company
could have done better in all those
cases we have the authority to make sure
that they do better that they resolve
those matters as they're required to by
law
um and for those cases for any one of
those 750 cases that we open
we have a process in our department
where none of them can be closed without
the consumer division
the director of the consumer division
our legal team the head of the division
and so we have two divisions life and
health and PNC the head of the division
and then the Deputy Commissioner and I
we all sit around a table and uh in
triage each one of these cases as they
close and we do that for two main
purposes one we want to ensure that
everybody around that table agrees this
is the right result for the consumer but
more importantly we want to ensure that
we all understand what's happening on
the ground here in New Hampshire if
there's a issue that's emerging a
coverage dispute issue or a processing
thing with an insurance company that's
happening we want to know about that
ahead of time so that we can either have
an enforcement action or an
investigative action to make sure those
companies get into line we find it's the
best way to deliver consistent and
appropriate resolutions for our New
Hampshire consumers
um as part of because the insurance is a
state regulated industry in large part
uh there are 56 other Commissioners
around the nation and territories that
do exactly what I do
and because we are such a small part in
the National Insurance Marketplace we
all all the Commissioners get together
uh several times a year to make sure
that we're all doing it kind of growing
in the same direction that we're
regulating these entities right we
belong to a group called The National
Association of insurance Commissioners
to make sure that happens so that states
like New Hampshire can benefit from
bigger states that are addressing issues
before we are but also for when we find
out about an issue something like I
talked about our consumer division we
see a company who's breaking the law we
know who to call and all the other
states are doing business and saying
take a look
um it works very well for us
I think that's a basic summary of what
we do obviously we do a lot more at the
department that's a basic summary of
what we do I think it's important for
all of you to know that the resources
that exist at the department are
available to all all constituencies of
the state but to you and to your
constituents and so when you're
somewhere at the parade or town hall or
a dump and someone says I'm having a
question about
anything Insurance feel free to call me
directly I will triage that call and get
you to the person on our team that's the
expert
um that's I I find the best way for you
to deliver value to your constituent but
also to make sure that that matter gets
to the right person immediately
oftentimes if you make that call to me
during uh eight to four Thirty I will
literally as we're talking on the cell
phone walk directly to whoever the
expert subject matter expert is in our
office and we will will be on the phone
with your constituent that day
um I think and the packet here is our
cell phone number to the office I'm
sorry the mainline number to the office
my cell phone is 603.
zero three five nine
thank you Amy
thank you for having me
no the trick was I was going to mumble
those
zero three five nine
okay so thank you for having me today
today I'm going to review with you our
historical Revenue uh where that money
comes from the factors that will impact
that revenue and then we're going to
look for it at our projections for the
future so we'll start off on slide six
that has our planned Revenue to our
actual results as reported in the annual
comprehensive financial report you'll
see that fiscal year
2022 was a very strong year where it was
16 million over the prior fiscal year
um I'd also like to point out that in
four of those years you're looking at
Revenue did decrease from prior fiscal
year
so we do tend to have swings in revenue
from year to year and one of those
reasons right off the bat how we
calculate our premium taxes is we calc
we collect the premium taxes in advance
so when we get our premium tax returns
in March we will be collecting the 2022
taxes we will then subtract out the
estimated prepayment that was made on
their prior year tax return and that
will true up their 2022 taxes and then
we will collect a hundred percent of
that tax liability as a prepayment for
2023. so if they are increasing their
writings that will increase their true
up and increase their prepayment so that
is a double swing
now to look at where this revenue is
coming from our largest source of
Revenue is collected through the premium
taxes which accounts for about 80
percent
of our revenue or 120 million last year
and the other 20 is coming from our fees
and our penalties
so the largest source of the premium tax
revenue is from the licensed insurers we
have 49 domestics here in the state the
others are domiciled in the other states
or foreign companies
and like Chris said there's
approximately 1300 returns we'll be
collecting come March
these are Property and Casualty
companies that write lines of business
such as home and auto and workers comp
we collect from life insurance companies
accident and health insurance and
straight health or medical
we're also collecting from risk
retention groups and purchasing groups
and from licensed producers that have
Surplus lines Authority that accounts
for about three and a half percent of
the eighty percent I mentioned and we
are collecting from independently
procured business but that's a small
piece less than one percent of our
Revenue
from for the taxes and fees the 20 that
I mentioned that is primarily from our
producers and our investors
now to dive into the taxes that we're
collecting a little deeper the licensed
companies and the risk retention groups
both paying 1.25 on our property cash
casualty lines of business and two
percent on our accident and health lines
of business
there is a minimum tax of two hundred
dollars per licensed company
and we do have an employee in place a
retaliatory provision which is meant to
equalize the tax burden across all
states for these companies so we will
actually collect the higher of the New
Hampshire tax rate or the tax rate of
the company state of domicile
so come March 15th this year we will be
collecting close to 1300 tax returns
um and these insurers like I mentioned
they're going to be paying their taxes
due for the calendar year 2022.
we're going to take out the estimated
prepayment that they made
on their tax return last year and then
they're going to pay a hundred percent
of that tax liability
for a prepayment for the calendar year
2023.
for the Surplus Lions producers we're
collecting three percent
on any policies that are covering risk
in our state
we are expecting at least 330 producers
to file a uh annual report and pay taxes
by January 31st so that is a busy time
for us right now
we will collect from independently
procured four percent on their the risk
that those are cover covering and those
are due March 1st but that like I said
is a very
very small piece of less than one
percent
the bar graph on the next page is the
historical View for the past 10 years
so you will see here in dollars the
fiscal year 2022 the licensed companies
that we just went over
it was 120 million
Surplus lines a little over 5 million
independently procured was less than a
million and the fees were 28 million and
like Chris mentioned we don't expect the
fees to continue at the levels that they
were this past fiscal year
now what are the factors that impact
this Revenue what causes it to swing
so for one thing it's the insurance
Market the insurance Market operates in
two different business Cycles
and they don't necessarily coincide with
the prevailing economic cycle
they can definitely vary by line of
business
we consider a hard Market to be when the
underwriting standards are stringent and
the prices will tend to increase and the
soft Market the underwriting standards
are much looser and the prices tend to
decrease
but we have all these other variables
that can cause Revenue to fluctuate
the largest is our tax base which is our
premiums written that will go down in
detail in the next couple slides
then we have the retaliatory premium Tax
Rate rates which I mentioned equalizes
the tax burden across States
that was 10 million of our revenue for
last year we have our retaliatory fees
and assessments and that accounted for 5
million of that Revenue
so
um let's see what else we have premium
tax credits that we give
we have amended returns that come in
throughout the year or we will revise
returns throughout the year as we go
through our audit process
that might cause additional Revenue
companies can re-domesticate to other
states which may affect their
retaliatory taxes or assessments
we have the producer in licensing volume
that will fluctuate we have examination
billing that will fluctuate based on the
number of open exams being conducted by
our financial regulation division or our
Market conduct unit
and we have enforcement penalties which
are hard to predict based on the nature
of of what they do
so the next slide with the pie chart
breaks out it shows you just our tax
base so in New Hampshire the license
companies wrote over seven billion
dollars worth
of premiums in New Hampshire
you will see from the pie chart that
that is split fairly evenly between the
Property and Casualty lines of business
at 38 and 39 percent of what was written
here followed by the life life insurance
at 20 and then the risk retention groups
and title insurance is just a little
sliver of the pie
the next SEC slide actually puts those
premium dollars in or premium dollars
broken out by the type of company
so again you'll see the health and the
Property and Casualty they're writing
over two billion dollars
in business here in New Hampshire
next we'll touch on how we derive our
projections at the department where we
have a team of experts that to get
together and discuss where we feel
revenue is heading we start with the tax
unit we'll analyze the annual statement
data that comes in
and we'll look at Revenue Trends from a
historical basis and we do this by
product line
we'll then sit down with the actuaries
at the department and the executives uh
the the actuaries are actually receiving
the rate filings from companies so they
know what requests have been put in what
the companies see the marketplace doing
whether they want the premiums to go up
or down and we rely on their growth
projections because there is a lag in
the time that we get the premium dot
figures from the neic
as the companies are do not file their
premium data until March of this year so
we won't have 2022 premiums until later
in March
so to take a look at what our fiscal
year 2023 authorized budget is we derive
this based on our premium tax base and
our tax credits and our fees
but if we go through line by line You'll
see that the premium tax liability
expected for 2022 was 18.6 Million
and then we're subtracting the
prepayment that was applied or what we
collected in March of last year you'll
see right there there was a 2.4 million
dollar swing of additional Revenue that
we'll be collecting
and then the companies need to pay 100
of that tax liability so they will for
2023 so they'll be submitting
118.6 million
then we are expecting from the
non-admitted market 4.6 million which is
primarily from the Surplus line
producers so we'll have a total premium
tax revenue projected to be
125.6 million
and then our licenses and fees projected
to be 18 million
and our transfer to Department of Health
and Human Services for the funding of
the Granite Health Trust Fund to be 8.6
million
which means our total revenue projected
will be 135 million
so looking at where we are so far this
fiscal year we've so far we've received
14.8 million which is a million less
than last year at this time and that is
attributable to the fee Revenue
decreasing thus far this year so
um
the last slide here
lays out our projections looking ahead
to fiscal year 24 and 25 in the same
manner
where for fiscal year 24 we're looking
for it to increase up to 139 million and
for fiscal year 25. it will increase
further to
142.42 million
that concludes our presentation do you
have any questions
very good presentation wonderful I had
served on Commerce for several terms so
this is a little bit of a repeat for me
but I'm sure there's going to be
questions we'll start over here and
we'll go around sound good
representative Schamberg thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question commissioner just one uh who
audits uh your department uh is it
strictly in-house or do you use any
outside of state government uh Auditors
uh we we obviously work with the state
uh Financial system but the LBA audits
us
other questions yes representative
fellows
um can you just explain to me what the
retaliatory provision is and how that
impacts because I have no idea what
you're doing sure it's that's a great
question and it it uh it shows that
you're paying attention because it
doesn't make sense but what happens is
New Hampshire uh four PNC products we
charge a New Hampshire company who's uh
producing Insurance here in the State uh
premium a sales tax of 1.25 percent
um but if a company outside of New
Hampshire is selling Insurance here in
the State uh we look at that company's
domicile state to see how they treat a
domicile New Hampshire company when
they're paying their sales tax and so if
uh if one of our
um one of our licensed companies here in
New Hampshire sell some insurance in
Massachusetts what we're looking at and
say what's massive sales tax on this
I'm making up a number two percent uh we
would charge those Mass companies two
percent here in New Hampshire we want to
we don't want to provide an incentive
for companies to from artists to
for other states out of New Hampshire to
charge a higher sales tax on our
domestic companies and so we treat them
as they treat our companies
all the questions on this side uh
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking our questions
um do companies pay quarterly the tax
they owe or is it uh in March at the um
when the tax is due they pay it a
hundred percent in advance or I guess
they pay it March for the entire year
based on their prior Year's sales and so
just as an example if a company writes a
lot of business in New Hampshire last
year and decides well we're not writing
business in New Hampshire next year when
they file their taxes in March they say
what they did for last year they pay the
tax and we charge them a projection of
tax for next year even though they're
not in the market that's how we collect
it and then we true it up in the march
of the next year
that we do that with all 1300 of them
I actually had a quick question because
I think I understood you you thought
that there was an aberration in premiums
uh
fees I guess and then it went really
high but then when I look at that on
your projections you see it looks like
it's going higher and higher
well um
no I think so
good question and what you are not
seeing is the actual number that came in
in the 23 budget uh that what we are
showing you here is the authorized
budget of 18 million the actual number
in 23 was 28 million oh and so
um that's the number we think we'll
moderate back down to 19. uh and to put
that all in context so that you're not
only just hearing what parts uh our
authorized budget for 23 was 135 million
are actual uh Revenue was 155 million
okay made up almost half of which by
fees that were out of line
thank you so much questions yes
representative Platt yes this I'm going
to show my newness of this committee
from Science and Tech
um page nine Revenue sources licensed
Surplus lines produces independently
procured not a bit of Market that's all
Greek to me what are they perfect two
different things so we have 1300
companies that write business in New
Hampshire and that covers almost all
types of risks that we would have here
there are risks that are very unique and
so think of the kinds of things you've
heard of Lloyd's of London insuring you
know Taylor Swift's legs the possibility
of a volcano disrupting a you know Super
Bowl things that are hard to kind of uh
to to get coverage for in New Hampshire
I think medical malpractice insurance is
an example of something that's real to
us all there aren't a lot of players in
New Hampshire selling that so if there
is not a market in New Hampshire from a
licensed company to get the coverage you
need you are permitted to get that
coverage from somebody licensed outside
of New Hampshire that's Surplus lines we
have requirements for trying to get it
in state before you leave the state and
purchase it outside so Surplus lines
insurance tax is higher because they're
not confined to the regulatory
control of our state and we don't want
to incentivize business to go that way
independently procure and so just on
service lines to close out that Loop the
producer the insurance agent who helps
you find that Circle of Science
Insurance in New Hampshire collects the
three percent and pays it to us
if the factor if the case uh existed
where a consumer didn't use an agent and
somehow directly got in contact with
Lloyds of London uh the obligation to
pay that and that is
uh four percent for independently
procured that is a very rare occurrence
uh chair chairman I think we skipped
some people on your right as we were
going around did we okay representative
Army
sorry I was still trying to understand
this you have not given us the actuals
that you actually have for uh FY 23.
as I understand it and on
155 million total 128 million from the
premium tax liability and then how much
from license fees and penalties so if
you've switched to page slide 15
I'm on slide 15. all right um I have
rounded numbers here premium tax
liability Top Line 124.
yep so it was a five point
something percent increase million
dollar increase uh the prepayment
applied was 117.17
. we're on Slide 15.
right is that not
no I'm giving you so uh apologize
representative if I wasn't being clear
what we have in slide 15 is our fiscal
year 2023 authorized budget I'm giving
you the actual numbers that align with
that authorized budget
yes absolutely
I'm sorry fiscal year 22.
the results I'm sorry so it's 124 1.
for premium tax liability
uh 117 6 per prepayment applied
1241 for prepayment of following year
because we charge the tax based on last
year's
we had 6.2 million for premium Tax
non-emitted Market
uh
the next line would be 136 million 800.
136 million eight hundred thousand
28 million for license fees and
penalties
uh 10 million two hundred thousand for
the Granite State Health Trust uh
payment
for 155. how much was the
United States
10.2 million
to
we will update this slide and send it
over yes that'd be very very helpful
thank you and uh representative Ames
thank you
so your reference to volcano sort of
triggered this question
um
that's totally unusual right but what
I'm wondering if if there are large risk
factors
that are affecting today's market
differently than before or that are new
and that are widespread and I guess I'm
thinking specifically of the change in
weather patterns that we're all
experiencing that may create greater
risk for insurers
so that's a good question and I think
New Hampshire is uniquely positioned to
you know we don't have a lot of
catastrophic losses here
uh but but insurance isn't local
insurance is National and the players
Across the Nation in in in part the
reinsurers across the world are looking
at weather related losses uh large cat
losses and its impact on the marketplace
the way we see that here in New
Hampshire because there are there isn't
a lot of potential kind of risk of of of
those kinds of count losses we see it in
reinsurance rates that New Hampshire
regulated companies are paying to uh to
reinsure parts of their books it's
getting harder for them to do that and I
think that ultimately will will
potentially result in some higher
premiums
all right
um let's we'll go back to representative
fellows and we'll bounce around and
we're just trying to make sure everyone
gets the first dibs go ahead
um thank you on on page 13.
I'm just what I see for a trend there is
I see that health insurance is just
escalating at a
alarming rate
and in your projections do you
how are how are you dealing with that
and
you know the property Property and
Casualty is Flowing up slowly but if you
look back just from
you know just on this chart
the health insurance is just
out of sight uh there are there are a
lot of factors here including that these
numbers include MCO
Medicare expansion in them
um and so these are impacted by by
Insurance greater than just the health
that you and all you and I are thinking
of
um and
I think we we base our projections on uh
for health uh impacts of the ACA in the
State uh we've done what we can to kind
of moderate increases in our um in our
health insurance premiums for the
regulated market uh a few years ago now
three years ago now uh we we got
permission to have a 1332 waiver which
was to use some money from the federal
government to provide some reinsurance
to our individual Marketplace which took
some of the risk out of it we took some
federal funds and applied a basically a
reinsurance program so that those
individual Market players didn't have
all of the downside risk and that was
very helpful in moderating our rates
um
but you know New Hampshire is not unique
in dealing with the rise in health care
costs
okay I saw some hands over here anything
yes representative Bolton
thank you madam chair um regarding other
factors impacting the General Revenue so
I'm wondering if a couple of minor ones
might be like access to certain data
sets like the hospital discharge data
set or Vital Records to have need or
have full access yeah but do believe we
have a need to we have access to
discharge data we also have the best in
the nation all claims to pay our
database New Hampshire was the first
it's almost almost 17 years ago now to
get permission to start collecting uh
virtually all Health Care claims data
that data allows us to understand our
Market it allows us to create our health
cost website which ultimately allows
consumers to price uh Health uh health
health procedures ahead of time
um and so I don't
we currently aren't looking at
large-scale uh product uh projects
dealing with new Health Data though we
are anticipating some of the payment
transparency requirements under the
federal law with kind of anticipation as
we see Hospital charges come through on
the national level
thank you
okay back around second round
representative almi
thank you um so the actuals from FY 22.
um the biggest jump was in the license
fees apparently and that's and you're
taking them down from 28 million to 19
million for well for 24. I'm not sure
what
um
23 was set up in 21 so
so I'm not sure where 23 fits in this
but how you
we we jumped up about a third and we're
going to lose that third is that what
we're looking at
it is not all in license fees it is
primarily license fees the the 200 000
licensees that were licensed Across the
Nation
um there are two things one license uh
license renewals happen on a a two-year
basis and so you have years that are
strong years and weak years uh coveted
covid changed that there are
um tens of thousands of insurance
licensees that either in this cycle or
next cycle will not be renewing a New
Hampshire insurance license they just
don't need that many
um I don't we don't know when that's
going to be
um but our team
can't rationalize that never staying at
28 million dollars there were also some
penalties in here uh which were one-time
payments not enough to to move the
needle but
so
is there a follow-up
this
these Cycles happen differently in each
state and that's why you can't
anticipate when you're going to get
hit with a low license here
um no the license our license is every
two years
they individual licensees who have
licensed in multiple States uh do not
need to keep all of their license it's
not you know if you're licensed in 13
states you know next year you may only
renew eight because you're not you don't
have a client that's in New Hampshire
anymore or or as you've Consolidated
your a Workforce you now have people
directed specifically to the New
Hampshire Market again I think
our best estimate is that during covid
they said license everybody everywhere
because we don't know who's going to be
working and we don't know where they're
going to be working because they didn't
have the call centers they used to
um
I may be back here in two years saying
I'm surprised but they've all kept the
licenses
but our best estimates are that we're
not going to that's
yeah thank you great thank you so much
um if you could update us and email the
committee an update on actual
we will we will provide that in a
replacement fantastic thank you so much
thank you
okay we will now recognize the judicial
branch Diane Martin and Donna Raymond
good morning
my name is Diane Martin I'm the director
of the administrative office of the
courts with me today is Donna Raymond
our fiscal manager who is really the
genius behind all of these numbers but
I'm here uh to to accompany her
um I'm relatively new to the judicial
branch so this is my first time with
this committee so nice to meet and see
everyone
um so I'll walk you through sort of the
high level information and then Donna is
going to jump in and walk you through
the numbers
I know all of you know most of most of
this but I think it's helpful to
understand the judicial branch Mission
which is to preserve the rule of law
while protecting the rights and
Liberties guaranteed by the United
States and New Hampshire constitutions
and our goal really is is detailed
further below and that is to provide
accessible prompt and efficient forms
for the fair and independent
administration of justice with respect
for the Dignity of all that we serve we
take that very seriously
um on the next page slide three you see
the breakdown of the judicial branch it
really has four major components Supreme
Court Superior Court Circuit Court and
then the administrative office of the
courts which provides all of the
Operational Support to all of the courts
including budgeting
the trial courts really are where we
produce all of the unrestricted Revenue
mainly the circuit court because that's
where you see the majority of the cases
that come to the judicial branch
uh our unrestricted Revenue breaks down
into several categories which I think
it's helpful to understand at a high
level
the first category is the fines that are
levied on individuals those generally
are motor vehicle fines which we all
know what those are criminal fines and
penalty assessments
another category of unrestricted Revenue
that the branch generates is the entry
fees and those are for when you file a
cause of action in the branch or you
bring emotion there's generally speaking
a fee associated with those
um then there's this miscellaneous
category of other fees and um it it
really houses a number of fees I think
Donna did a search yesterday and there
was something like 40 different fees in
that other fee category some are tiny
some are bigger one of those is I
highlighted separately the record
research requests and that's something
that's relatively new to the branch in
judge king the administrative judge of
the Circuit Court
had encountered I think
a real resource issue with the number of
requests the judicial branch gets for
information
from generally from businesses
in and outside of the State of New
Hampshire looking for information about
people and so these are the not
litigants coming in and saying I need
information about my case here's my case
number these are
businesses who want to do a research on
a person they're hiring or or a landlord
and so he was having a problem with our
court staff
doing research essentially for companies
and not being able to do the job that
they were there for so
he worked with the Supreme Court to
create a system where those record
requests are treated differently and we
actually have dedicated staff who focus
on those and since I had them run the
numbers yesterday since 2015 when that
was instituted I think it's generated
approximately 36 million dollars for the
general fund and it's been very
effective for the court as well so
wanted to highlight that success for you
so that's the general categories of
unrestricted Revenue
um
I can go into greater detail about the
specifics of Motor Vehicle criminal
penalty assessments anything that is of
interest to you or we can turn it over
to
to Donna
morning so I thank you so I thought what
I'd do is just start with some a little
more detail about the types of revenues
that we collect and where it deposits to
and then at the end we look at the
actual numbers for fiscal year 22 23
projected and 24 and 25.
so starting out with fines two main
types motor vehicle related and Criminal
so motor vehicle binds as you may have
some experience with are imposed by
either
state and local police
and they depending upon the level of
fine it may be plea by mail which means
you can just pay the fine directly to
the Department of Safety if it is a
higher level offense or if you wish you
have to have your case
um reviewed it will go to the courts but
assuming it's a plea by mail you pay it
directly to the Department of Safety
and along with it we'll get to that a
little bit later let's say you have a
hundred dollar fine that you can pay to
them there's also a penalty assessment
that gets tacked on of 24 so the actual
amount you would pay is 124 dollars but
of the hundred dollar amount that amount
is deposited to the highway fund
if you want to either it's something
that's a must appear and you have to go
to the court or if you want your case
heard before the court
and you are found guilty uh you have
your hearing and then the fine is also
imposed so you may have that same
hundred dollar fine that you have to pay
and you'll also be paying that twenty
four dollars for the penalty assessment
that gets tacked on same thing um that
hundred dollars deposits to the highway
fund so think of it as safety and the
court sort of doing motor vehicle and
they both are handled the same way the
fine portion goes to the general excuse
me the highway fund and then the penalty
assessment will get to a little bit
later and that splits in a few different
ways for criminal fines those are
imposed by the courts
they can be collected by Department of
Corrections field offices if an
individual is on probation or parole the
Department of Corrections collects the
criminal fines and they are deposited
into the general fund directly they do
not flow through us
if it's collected by the courts at the
time of sentencing the courts make every
effort to have you pay your fine at that
time
on your way out and if you are on the
individual is unable to pay their fine
at that time then they are LED into the
clerk's office and they have to sign
some forms whereby they are put on a
time payment plan there's also a 25 time
payment setup fee that they have to pay
as well so we don't always collect the
total fine amount at the time of
sentencing but the judges are trained to
make every effort to collect it at that
time
and again all of that is deposited to
the general fund
so now we talk a little bit more about
penalty assessments so they're levied on
fines imposed for criminal offenses
motor vehicle and violations of
Municipal ordinances
and by Statute the minimum is two
dollars or twenty four percent of the
fine I don't know anything we've ever
collected that's two dollars so I think
it's usually 24 of the fine
um and it used to be for those who have
been here a while
um prior to 2017
two-thirds of the penalty assessment
that we collected went to police
standards and training but over the
years penalty assessment revenues have
decreased to the point where police
standards and training said that they
could no longer operate with I think
that was their only source of funding so
things were changed and as a fiscal year
2017 the two-thirds that we collect of
it as well as safety now are deposited
to the general fund and police standards
and training is I believe funded by
General funds as well
so and just to complete that picture of
penalty assessment so the two-thirds now
are going to the general fund the other
two-thirds are split 1 6 going to a
dedicated fund which is the judicial
Branch's I.T dedicated fund and the
other one six going to the Department of
Justice's victims assistance fund which
is also a restricted fund
so
and then in terms of fines
collectibility
um so individuals who have to pay court
ordered motor vehicle fines are
defaulted through the department of who
fail to pay I'm sorry are defaulted
through the department of safety so
Department of Safety sends a warning
notice to the individual if the fine
remains unpaid the driver's license and
registration are suspended
and if it gets suspended many states
have reciprocity so meaning a driver's
license will be suspended in the state
in which they reside if they have that
on paid fine in New Hampshire
and if they wish to clear the default a
50 administrative fee is collected when
that fine is paid and that is also
deposited to the general fund
um rest orders are issued for unpaid
fines also in misdemeanor and felony
cases and there's a electronic registry
of bench warrants that get issued and
law enforcement can search the
repository for all outstanding bench
warrants in the state so if you get
stopped for something else they can see
that you may have an outstanding bench
warrant for an unpaid fine and address
it at that time as well
so the next type of
fee that we collect are the entry fees
they're also called filing fees entry
fees are set by Court rule and are paid
at the time of filing and they range
from forty five dollars to 225 dollars
and some of the common types that we
have are small claims landlord tenant
family civil petition to a null a
criminal record motion to bring forward
and the distribution of the entry fees
is set by Statute so 64 percent
currently of Entry fees are deposited to
the general fund
and then just to complete that picture
the remaining 36 percent of Entry fees
are deposited into judicial branch
restricted funds 30 to our I.T dedicated
fund and six percent to facilities
escrow so again there's two components
to that the actual amount of the entry
fee which the court sets and then how
that monies get distributed which is set
in statute
there can be a waiver of filing fee so
judges have the discretion to waive
entry fees for people who cannot afford
to pay because all citizens are entitled
to access to the courts to resolve their
disputes
foreign
and then there are the other fees so the
majority of revenues and other fees as
Diane mentioned is records research fees
and we did a study an analysis of fiscal
year 22 actuals in the other category
and 78 percent of it in the order of 6.5
million dollars was records research fee
so it is a significant amount of Revenue
and we charge uh twenty dollars per name
for the first five names and five
dollars per game for each additional
search
and then the majority of the the rest of
it is motions and petitions
and those fees range from 25 to 250
dollars but again they panel in
comparison to what records research fees
brings in in the other fees category
we also charge a 25 surcharge to civil
and family case filing fees
but there are some to which we don't
um criminal juvenile domestic violence
stalking small claims and landlord
tenant
and again if you're going to do a time
payment as I mentioned earlier there's a
25 setup fee that's assessed for that to
happen
I just want to and I know it's on the
slide but point out that those fees are
are set by Statute and so
um the legislature has determined that
those fees should either be assessed or
not assessed in the various cases
so then we get to the actual numbers
and
so we have a description of the type of
Revenue that we collect and there's two
sections there's the revenues that go to
the general fund at the top and at the
very lower section there is the revenue
that goes to the highway fund which is
our motor vehicle fines
so on the top section we look at actuals
for fiscal year 2022
actuals through the first half of fiscal
year 23 then we do a production for all
of 23 and then projections for 24 and 25
based on what we've seen over the years
so as you can see here the other fees
category again which contains the
records research fees is the largest
portion of that Revenue in excess of
eight million dollars
entry fees are next
and again those are filings for
different types of motions and petitions
and whatnot at 3.4 percent
penalty assessments is also fairly large
around 1.2 million
and then
we if anyone has any questions I'll
answer them but then we look at the
first half of fiscal year 23 and those
revenues are coming in lower than fiscal
year 22 and I was a little surprised by
that obviously we saw the impact of the
pandemic on the last quarter of fiscal
year 20 and then fiscal year 21.
and we're seeing a nice rebound into 22
and I was hoping we would continue to
see that Trend in 23.
um
and we thought about that and I think
some of that may just be General economy
right now I mean grocery prices are
frightening and food is something that
everybody needs to buy oil prices have
been very fluctuating people have to
heat their homes with oil it's been I
mean my last oil fill up was over a
thousand dollars I mean I have never had
to pay that much for oil so I think
people are really feeling it and also we
have some really nasty viruses that
aren't even covid going around people
have been sick for a month so that may
contribute to people out of necessity
not being on the roads as much or just
trying in any way they can to save money
here or there and you have a lot more
work from home that is accepted than
used to be prior to the pandemic so they
may be utilizing that option as well so
it may be that we're just seeing fewer
cars on the road as well affecting motor
vehicle fines I mean that's like a 7.3
percent
projected reduction in 23 versus 22
that's pretty significant I don't like
to be the Debbie Downer and I'd love to
be proved wrong but I didn't just take
the the first half of 23 and multiply it
by two I did look at you know the second
half of the year there's a slight uptick
over the first half of the year and I
did incorporate that versus what I've
seen
over several fiscal years in the past as
well to sort of inform what I think you
know the the second half of 23 would be
we're still coming in pretty low
mhm
I just wanted to add too I I did um
talk this through a little bit with uh
judge Kane to get a sense of what his
impression of the the um
reduction is and and he said on the fine
side he can't say this with scientific
certainty but his impression was that to
a certain extent the lack of
availability of public defenders
has caused the criminal cases to back up
and so
um you're not seeing the outcomes of
that which often include fines
um so just that was another piece and
then all of the similar things that
Donna said related to the economy
um also being part of why there may not
be as much revenue coming in
so then I applied sort of the same
rationale looking at the last several
fiscal years to see how revenues have
trended
to look at fiscal year 24 and excuse me
n25
and
so that first line default fees
collected by safety I spoke with Steve
Lavoy to get his insights as to where he
thought that was going he thought he
hoped that they would Trend up in fiscal
year 23
um 24 and 25. I'm hoping he's right
um but you know the first half of 23 is
a little over 250 000 so double that is
500 so he's hoping for I think for a big
uptick in the second half of this fiscal
year and again I hope that comes true
and he's got some moderate increases for
24 and 25.
um some of these numbers are really
small so the for instance interest you
know
it's going to be really small so it's
you see it you know a 30 percent decline
predicted it doesn't really have a big
fiscal impact one way or the other
because we're literally talking a few
dollars here so I don't really worry
about those
um the bigger hitters would obviously be
um fines as Diane commented on Entry
fees
and again we're seeing a reduction this
year and it may just be people being
more careful about or selective about
what they go to court for
and So based on some of the things I've
seen in the past
I'm thinking there may be a decline in
24 but hoping for an uptick in 25 as we
really hopefully get away from the
pandemic
and another big one is other fees Again
Records research but that's been you
know that's been healthy over the years
so I've kind of kept that at a moderate
increase year after year
for the next couple of fiscal years and
then penalty assessments I do see going
down penalty assessments like motor
vehicle has been one of those that over
the years has just had a steady decline
um maybe there will be some upticks like
again I hope I'm wrong but I just want
it to be realistic about what I've seen
probably over the last 10 fiscal years
in terms of what's been going on with
that and wanted to reflect that in these
projections so as not to be too overly
optimistic because I know you have to
use these numbers for determining what
you think you'll have for General funds
for 24 and 25. motor vehicle again
sort of related to penalty assessments
and fines that's been coming down over
the years I'm hoping clearly that it
will not be a steep a decline as I'm
looking at in 23 so we thought maybe a
one percent reduction in each of 24 and
25.
and then I don't we can go to questions
on the numbers
um but then the last page is just a more
detailed description of what is in each
of those
fine cat you know Revenue categories
and what's been happening perhaps over
the years because things have changed in
terms of what has happened what the
fines one thing I will point out is bar
exam fees
um they're not bar exam fees anymore
back in
2012. they had been bar exam fees and
were assigned to revenue code 402477 but
then there was a change by Supreme Court
rule on September 1 of 2012 and those
bar exam fees were then deposited to the
office of bar admissions
so instead of them being bar exam fees
now it's really certificates of good
standing that are collected there and I
had at the time talked to I think it was
then fdm to see if we could get that
name changed the problem is the name
changes historically all the way back so
they weren't too keen on doing that an
alternative would be just to keep this
explanation so you know it's not really
bar exam fees or to ask for another
revenue account I I know boa doesn't
have a ton of them that they like to
give out but if this committee really
doesn't like this or isn't comfortable
with it I can request to have a new
revenue account set up I don't know if
they'd be able to take though
the revenues that are currently being
put into this that are really
certificates of good standing and move
it to this new revenue account so I'm
not even sure how clean that transition
could be but I just I put it out there
just so you're clear it's not an
accurate description of what the revenue
is in there
excellent very good presentation okay
questions starting with uh
representative Schamberg
thank you madam chair thank you madam
director uh just one question who audits
the judicial branch how often and one
was the most recent one if you don't
have that information maybe you can send
it
um I cannot remember off the top of my
head the last external audit at the
internal components of the judicial
branch are audited for example our I.T
department just had an audit focused on
certain parts we also have internal
audit and they routinely audit the trial
courts and end of
um
this calendar year did a full risk
assessment of the judicial branch and
are currently auditing the various
components based on risk so internally
it's ongoing externally LBA but I can't
recall the last one but I'll get you
that
representative self-worth
thank you for taking my question I've
heard a couple reports about the fact
that speeding has increased and that
also the speeding is at higher speeds so
I thought it might show up in the fines
yeah that's always a hard one
to discuss because it's it's probably a
few factors that are involved in it um
again people working from home more
probably less cars on the road
um bad Economic Times I mean I can't
speak for what goes on out there um if
you get stopped and you're in tears and
saying you're going to a job interview I
don't know what happens you know it's
not for me to speak to that there may be
some of that going on some forgiveness
of you know imposing a fine
um and obviously we had the speed limits
increased up in the north country from
you know 65 to 70. I think we saw a
little bit of a difference in fines as a
result of that change that happened a
few years ago or 2017 whatever that was
thank you
other questions on this side uh
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking us question
um
I was just wondering if um maybe the
increase in 2022 some of it might be
from the fact that I know
being a landlord myself and talking to
other landlords they were frustrated for
a while that they couldn't bring you
know tenant actions so there was a big
backlog but in 2022 that backlog started
breaking so I'm wondering if maybe that
helped push up did you did you see a big
increase in that category that might
account for some of this
we haven't looked at it to that level I
believe we have the ability to do that
so I would be happy to go back and
research that if you would like that
answer
that'd be great
I will say though I think and and it is
it is going to take some time to see why
we saw a rebound in FY 22 and then sort
of this drop off I don't know if this is
just
um as Donna said the economy and then
multiple factors or and we're going to
see that rebound but what you're seeing
here is as compared to FY 22 so prior to
that we had a couple of years where you
know we were lower I think we definitely
saw an increase in court activity in FY
22 as we came out of that people were
coming back to the courts the courts
were operating in the way that they
normally did so I think we saw an
increase I'm not sure if it was just in
that category across the board
other questions
representative Phyllis
um I'm I'm just wondering what the chart
might look like on page 10 if if it had
gone back a couple more years so it was
before covid
did do you recall what that looks like I
have those numbers I did not bring them
to this presentation but yeah I have
them going back quite a few years
actually so
uh
trying to remember
I mean obviously 21 was not great
um 20 wasn't I mean it was a deep cut at
the last quarter of 20 as well if you
wouldn't mind why don't we why don't we
uh request that if we could if you could
update that page 10
um with a new one and go back how many
years would we thinking
I was just wanting to see what it looked
like before covid right so maybe go back
could you go back four years three four
years yeah
I was going to say Donna did actually
put that together so I have a
perspective I think that's helpful going
back to about 2015 and you really can
see the impacts of statutory changes
that are unrelated to the pandemic then
you can see that's 2015 2017. then you
can see
um the the significant impact of the
pandemic in 2020
and and the downside and then this 22
uptick so it's I think it would be
really helpful to have I mean there were
two things that come to mind that
impacted it one was
um there were eight case Types on the
uniform fine schedule that safety puts
out that went from um must appear to
plea uh to plea by mail so hopefully the
same amount of Revenue but you're seeing
a decrease on the court side and an
increase probably on the department of
safety side because people can now do
plea by mail for those the other thing
was the decriminalization of marijuana
that had about a seven hundred thousand
dollar reduction to
um what we collected in fines
um going forward so
uh I see your questions over here
representative Platt yeah I did go back
to uh 20 at least 2019 maybe 2018 2020
is when covet hit almost died from it
but it happened in 2020. yeah I was
going to do fiscal year 17 and on
so
and just a reminder folks we're going to
be hearing from the Department of Safety
a little bit later today so we can maybe
ask them a few of these questions okay
great thank you so much
thank you
okay looks like we have the Lottery
Commission next welcome
okay we have Charlie McIntyre and James
durris welcome
as a reminder for the record I am a
lottery licensee love a lot of their
products thank you
okay
um good morning uh Madam chair members
of the Ways and Means Committee my name
is Charlie McIntyre this says Charles
only my mom calls me Charles
um and with me is our Chief Financial
Officer Jim Durst and I'll go through
the slides rather briefly Madam chair if
please the commit committee and then
I'll be happy to answer questions
remember Jim and I will answer questions
afterwards the presentation was
essentially to explain what it is we do
and certainly this hopefully will at
least start the process of explaining
what does we do
um
so if you go to the first slide that's
essentially a breakdown of our
organizational chart
of how the lottery is now situated we've
gone through a number of organizational
changes and we'll continue to do so as
we evolve the operations of the lottery
obviously it's broken down in such a
three major components product and
program is really sales marketing
and it's equivalent
um
our chief compliance officer is the
individual responsible for making sure
both we and the retail retailers we
license and operate are in compliance
with our rules regs and the law and
operations is in charge of obviously
maintaining the trains on time uh day to
day week to week
we have three appointed Commissioners
the lottery acts a little differently
than most departments
um we have three appointed Commissioners
who act like a board of directors who
meet monthly to determine sort of core
strategy long term very much like a
corporation
I'll go through sort of each product
category
uh that the lottery has first is instant
games which you would characterize as
scratch tickets this is all this
information is contained in our annual
report which is also submitted to the
legislature at the fiscal committee I
think next week
um but this is a snapshot of it and
certainly our annual report is on our
website
um it is annually sent to the government
financial offices Association and it is
gfoa certified annually for 17 18 years
running
um Instant tickets is essentially
scratch tickets
it's the largest product we sell by unit
it is sold obviously through our retail
Network it accounts for approximately 53
million dollars of our profit annually
the next slide is the products we sell
in concert and in collaboration with our
neighbors Maine and Vermont
in the tri-state compact which was
signed in 1986 it was the first
multi-state agreement between lotteries
signed by then governor sununu
um with the first game Tri-State mega
bucks and now we sell four Central
categories of products
um give me five fast play Megabucks and
the daily numbers games of pick three
and pick four
uh the next slide are the products we
sell nationally as part of our
collaboration
uh the most well-known obviously is
Powerball it is the most known brand
other than Apple and Google in the US
Mega Millions is a product we've been
selling now for 15 years we joined a
Consortium that did cross-sell
originally Powerball was sold by such
States
Mega Millions was sold by some states
and then they cross sold and they've
been in existence for 15 years Lucky for
Life was launched in 2014 I believe
I'm sorry 2012.
and that was originally the New England
states and now that game is National
the next slide
is three products we've launched within
the last six years
Keno 603
buy Lottery and sports betting through
DraftKings
Kino was launched
in 17 we've sold our first ticket in
December of that year
we now sell about 53 million dollars
annual inquino for a profit of about 10
million
ilottery was launched the following year
um
and currently ilottery represents it's a
essentially you can buy Powerball and
Mega Millions through your phone as well
as play scratch tickets through your
phone
profitability for that is about 23
million
and then DraftKings was launched in 2019
our sports betting platform as our
partnership
it's more of a we own the rights to it
and DraftKings is our vendor we have a
contract with them which is approved by
the executive Council
last year our profitability for that was
23 million dollars
um
and uh something we're particularly
proud of the next slide
this is last fiscal years revenues by
state what the state received New
Hampshire was number two
we received 23 million dollars for a per
capita state revenue of 16.95
that compares favorably with virtually
everybody else and so we were able to
retain the funds that other states gave
away to others
in some states you're talking two or
three dollars uh the factor of eight to
one versus other states
um
the next slide is essentially sports
betting since we launched
um the first year was
hampered significantly by covid
as you can imagine in the summer of 20
there was virtually nothing to bet on
because there were no Sports we were
taking action in burundian soccer and
you know Russian table tennis I'm not
kidding Russian table tennis at the time
was our number one product
and you will know that we banned Russian
table tennis betting along with Russian
vodka uh happened similarly
um and so
um we are one of the most profitable
jurisdictions in the world for sports
betting in terms of the for the state
getting Revenue uh and New York is now
number one and they copied us quite
literally so
um all that leads to my our next slide
which is the which is my chief our chief
financial officer's favorite Slide the
distributions to education
uh over the last 15 years you'll see
significant growth
what you will not see which is really
what our CFO was most proud of is an
increase in our administrative expenses
that blue line is essentially flat year
over year so that we've been able to
grow revenue and not increase expenses
um
you know we run the lottery like a
business very much so because that's how
we're asked to do it to maximize Revenue
in a responsible way so that's what we
do
and the suggestion would be is because
we added all these products
that's how we grew Revenue
um I'm proud to announce that we're the
number one jurisdiction in North America
in Powerball sales per capita where the
for high lottery sales we're number two
jurisdiction for Mega Million sales per
capita we're the number two jurisdiction
for Keno sales per capita and number two
slash three for sports betting per
capita so it's not just a matter of you
added more stuff
um we have done it really efficiently
really effectively uh really well and
we're super proud of that so the last
slide I don't expect you to read and
digest immediately it is essentially
revenues expenses
um changes in that position for the last
10 years
and this is our this is our Bible this
is our this is technically Gemini's
report card
um and this is also in our financial
report available on our website
previously we used to send you folks a
copy of that we got in trouble with
admin services for making 400 copies of
a document this big
um so it's now available on our website
to download or read it's very long I
suggest not printing it at home
um
I'm trying to be fast I know you folks
are behind happy to answer any questions
we do or what we do as to how we do it
or why we do it
wow that was fast
I see folks behind I don't know what I
know sorry lunch is upon us right okay
I'm gonna start over here questions
representative shamberg
thank you madam chair thank you
Mr director uh just one question it has
to do with equipment
does the Lottery Commission do
investment in equipment for the outlets
without the cost to the store owner and
the reason I bring this up is that it
seems that some of the places I stopped
continually tell me we can't do your
ticket today or because
we're shut down or something I don't
know if there's a connection between
that or something with the store
um certainly when um the central system
and the terminals that are at retail are
part of an overall contract that we bid
out for procurement and we're at the end
of that contract
um the capital expenses for that are
extreme so we have to have a longer term
contract than we'd ideally like because
it's
essentially buying a computer at every
terminal at every store
buying a large terminal which holds the
tickets you'll pass in a supermarket
those collectively are like 17 18 000.
a central system which costs Millions to
build
and three other duplicate locations
which maintain our data so for example
if you place a Powerball wager at your
store that signal
if you can do it yeah that signal hits
our Central system and our backup data
center simultaneously that signal is
then split and it goes to two separate
systems which are called ICS
it's it all all four low systems match
the wager send it back through the
communications Network which there are
four Communications networks we support
that has to occur under four seconds or
less with an accuracy of 100 percent
we do not have failures if it's a
failure it's a non-ticket every drawing
we have to balance every dollar and
every ticket we do not have errors uh in
fact if we have an error the drawing is
held back and that's across the nation
every night so it's a it's a very
complicated system because that all has
to happen oh sorry in four seconds or
less so we're end of life on the
technology we have in the field now and
we're about to go out to bid for new
technology and new investment of product
and that that gets expensive as you can
imagine
so it's one of those we we rely on a
vendor oit could never do that are you
telling me I should go to another store
Yeah okay or actually actually more
importantly you can use your phone
I've tried that approach I'm not even
going to get there oh
now I see a lot we'll start with this
corner representative yes thank you I'm
just looking at the last page here and
it may just be my inability to
understand what I'm reading here
um the revenues expenses changes in net
position for the last 10 years
it is the net position I mean I'm
looking with the parentheses around
those bottom numbers I would it's not a
negative number
it is a negative number it's a retained
earnings number okay all right all right
all right here's that yep okay all right
again it's just the change we have
Holdings that are with uh muscle and
Tri-State and and for uh
uh inflows of Revenue or restricted
funds excuse me and changes in that are
generally what affect our net position
at the end of the year okay uh this year
was a little bit different which you'll
see there was a little bit more of a
change than normal but that goes back to
the purchase of our building but that's
generally the only thing that really
affects that change so retained earnings
would be inaccurate okay thank you
representative fellows thank you madam
chair
um I was just looking through here and I
don't see anything about
um the current fiscal year to date or
your estimate for the biennium okay
um I wasn't I didn't know I was supposed
to do that I happily to submit one
um I mean certainly currently we are 21
million I had a plan
and our current plan is for 139 million
dollars
so you know the red we've asked for
these presentations at a high level
overview some of them were able to
provide Revenue estimates already some
are not able to uh we will begin more
in-depth actual Revenue analysis on the
22nd I think we decided of February
because we do need to hear the budget's
address at the budget address from the
governor then it goes to finance and
then we need a little bit of time to get
it from lbao to us so there's a little
bit of a delay there but I wanted to
make sure you had a great high-level
overview of what all these agencies do
okay next representative self-worth
thanks this is partly for later but um
are you sensing I'd say stability uh in
your older
um items and then maybe room for growth
in the newer things that you've just
added
um
the short answer is yes the short answer
is yes and yes with a caveat
we're still seeing
sales growth in older products in new
channels and what I mean by that is
another Powerball is you're going to buy
it through your phone no one fears a
snowstorm anymore
um or Mega Millions ticket you can now
buy it on a Friday use your phone use
your computer and you don't have to go
to a store and risk you know
brisk it so the insurance but otherwise
yes uh sports betting is continuing to
grow
um that may be impacted by masses launch
this week retail and then mobile they
launch in March but we'll know then you
know and adjust accordingly
representative almie
sure
sorry
um do we have and you said that the
Massachusetts going online with
something may impact this on do we have
an idea how many people were getting
coming across the border to
so for mobile we for mobile we do more
actually than we do for retail mobile
because you sign up with your phone you
can sign up in Massachusetts but you
have to be in physical locations New
Hampshire before you can bet so we know
how many folks in Mass it's about 25
percent a little more wow and so retail
we don't specifically know because you
can walk in about 100 and we wouldn't
know who you were we would only know who
you were if you bet above certain levels
uh and you had to fill out paperwork
yeah but we could lose a significant
amount of money with yeah so certainly
it's it's in play I mean
that's a good question I don't know the
answer yet I I was more fearful until I
saw New York New Jersey when New York
went live New Jersey thought it would
lose a lot of Revenue it hasn't yet so
I'm optimistic
but but certainly it's in play
representative it's a good question
and if I could follow up what is the uh
the general idea of how much it's going
to cost you for Capital costs to do the
new bid
uh so our business how do you package
that out over years yeah exactly so one
of the reasons we do the bid for as long
as we do is because the cap X costs are
so high
um
but it's a part of a REV share model and
so the contract is done based on a
percentage of sales so our current
platform is about
1.9 cents per dollar estimating
for sales of Lottery through terminals
that's how the vendor gets paid
it doesn't it's not a budget item if
that's your question representative
yes representative Platt yes I see the
number of type different types of
lottery games you have and be gamble if
I pick the right one uh how do you you
keep track of revenues by each I presume
and would drop one that's lost its
popularity
yes and we have in the past there have
been multiple certainly but during my
tenure there's been multiple games we've
dropped and changed to adapt
fundamentally the the strategy of the
last seven years has been to be additive
for example Keno sales
previously I was the general counsel of
the Mass lottery
about 20 million dollars in keynote
sales was happening in Massachusetts by
New Hampshire citizens so a lot of the
money that's Keno sales is money we just
repatriated
similarly sports betting I I use a joke
all the time but I guarantee you there
were sports betting going on in the
state before we legalized it uh and so
as a former prosecutor of organized
crime my friends in law enforcement tell
me we have absolutely annihilated the
bookmakers absolutely annihilated them
because we offer a better product faster
service government regulation guaranteed
payouts at a product that is similar to
the legal market and so
um
where it has made sense we have drop
products and change or change them and
where it has made sense we've added
products that were not
cannibalization it would be the correct
term
all the questions on this side of the
room
no back over here other questions
it must be lunch time
great thank you so much and uh we'll
have you come back so if you can be
prepared to bring your Revenue estimates
that'd be great thank you thank you
Chris Shea is with us he is the master
of everything that we're doing now with
revenues he is also coordinating the
agendas for us and everything so big
round of applause
let me succeed first
I just wanted to tell everybody that you
have this the actor in front of you so
that's the annual comprehensive
financial report if you're really
interested in it fiscal committee on
Friday there's a presentation by the
Auditors so it'll be in the afternoon at
one o'clock it'll be streamed obviously
so if you want to watch it you know this
weekend when you have nothing else to do
you're able to do that what I did want
to just point out to you is that on page
seven I believe it is
so that's a a table showing you all your
unrestricted general fund and education
trust fund revenues
and it shows you what was collected in
fiscal year 20
21 and 22 and then the last column shows
you the combined plan so you can get a
sense of
where you came in with 22 and how did it
compare to the plan that was in place
for fiscal year 22.
the other place I wanted to bring your
attention to is Page 148
and that page is a 10-year history of
your general fund revenues
so if you just wanted to see how they
were trending you could get a sense
there
just keep in mind if you see big dips or
or growths you may want to explore a
little bit more to see why that might
have occurred
and then
um go to page 150 will be education
trust fund revenues
there's a lot more stuff in this report
but I just wanted to draw this
committee's attention to those three
places
um and just to make you aware that the
audit presentation would be happening on
Friday if anybody was interested in
listening or attending or or
excuse me uh Friday it's in room 210 and
it'll starts at one o'clock
um and as representative Sanborn had
said um you know I'm in the process of
trying to schedule reschedule your
Monday I think we're going to be meeting
on February 7th with those agencies that
were scheduled for Monday
um with the addition of Health and Human
Services and the Department of Justice
Department of Justice will talk to you
about tobacco settlement and um
Health and Human Services we'll talk to
you about recoveries
I get to speak to you this afternoon in
lieu of Health and Human Services
unfortunately because of the delay some
we weren't able to kind of I wasn't able
to give you a kind of a
here's what's going to what's to expect
these few days and you got Charlie who
didn't give you the 23 24 25 the
presentation to the agencies was you're
coming into explaining to the house Ways
and Means Committee who you are and what
types of revenues you collect we'll
bring you back later if we need to as we
need to to talk about your revenues
knowing that some agencies as you've
seen are providing you that 23 24 and
25. if we had met on Monday dra would
have just talked about the revenues that
they collect but you wouldn't have
gotten any estimates because
we would like them to get their
estimates you know close to the end of
this month or estimate the end of
February so you can see
um a better sense of what the the
revenues are as well as the governors
would be out so you'd have an
understanding when if you see a
Governor's estimate in business taxes
it's higher than you would have expected
you could talk to dras to what might
have caused that to occur because they
they're involved with that
um but at 2 30 today when I get to speak
I'll just kind of go through what my
role will be with the committee some of
you are familiar with that others may
not know
um but again I don't want to take away
from your lunch but I just want to make
sure everybody understood why this
document was in front of you and a
couple of key pages to look at if you
wanted
thank you so much we will reconvene at
one o'clock to continue presentations
and then I'll give you another update on
the plan thanks
foreign
especially since there may be some
precipitation in our near forecast
welcome to rays and means uh we have
Department of Safety Steve Lavoy and
Scott Breyer here to give us a
presentation thank you for joining us
well thank you for having us
so good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee Steve Lavoy I'm the
director of administration for the
Department of Safety and with me is
Scott Breyer who is the bureau chief of
the road toll Bureau on the road till
Bureau is what collects the state's gas
tax for the highway fund so we'll be
presenting today on our our Highway fund
unrestricted Revenue collections I do
have a one slide or two on General funds
which are a very small portion of what
we collect just for situational
awareness but we'll go into a lot of
detail about the highway fund portion
which is predominantly road toll and DMV
related Revenue collections so on your
presentation on page two as a brief
overview of the Department of Safety our
vision is to make New Hampshire the
safest state in the nation with the
highest quality of life for all and our
mission is to continually enhance the
safety security and quality of life in
New Hampshire through professional
collaborative and Innovative service to
all
we have seven divisions within the
department of safety and also the office
of the commissioner that provides
overall leadership and support to all of
those functions the seven divisions are
listed here and as I mentioned the
division of administration which is
where the road toll Bureau sits and also
the Division of Motor Vehicles are the
two points of collection for Highway
fund revenues
on page three
the two Revenue sources for unrestricted
funding include Highway funds of
approximately 258 million
those funds are collected through road
toll which is the state's gas tax Motor
Vehicle registrations operate operators
which is a driver license program motor
vehicle certificates of title
inspections and then there's
miscellaneous revenues as well and there
are some significant general fund
resources Revenue sources of 9 million
in total those are collected at the DMV
admin and then also fire safety and
State Police
and there's uh those will go into a
little bit of detail at the end of the
presentation
so we'll start off with Highway funds if
you look to page five
total Highway funds collected in fiscal
year 22 or 258.3 million
and that amount was 7.4 million more
than our plan of 250.9 million
in FY 23 we're projecting to collect
257.5 million in Highway fund Revenue
which is about 4 million less than our
plan of 253.5 million I'm sorry more
than 253.5 million
um
overall Highway fund revenues in general
have increased at an annual rate of 1.2
percent between FY 16 and FY 22. so
really the increases in revenues have
not kept pace with the increases in
costs that those revenues support
revenues in the highway fund support
both the Department of Transportation
work on New Hampshire's roads as well as
the department of safety areas of state
police commissioner's office some other
areas as well so this has really created
a structural deficit in the fund itself
where the revenues aren't sufficient to
meet the operating needs as intended in
fact last biennium the legislature
transferred 50 million dollars in
general funds into the highway fund just
to ensure that that fund could balance
in the next in the next biennium so it's
important to to note that the revenues
are being collected but fees haven't
increased in in some time and so the
overall Revenue growth is um I mean less
than one percent is not a significant
growth area it's not keeping up with
expenditures
next I'll turn it over to our bureau
chief Scott Breyer to talk a little bit
about road toll operations
my name is Scott Breyer the road toll
Bureau is stately responsible for
collecting all the motor fuel tolls also
known as the gas tax and we enforce
compliance with a motor vehicle road
toll law through its uh through our
field audit Bureau
uh the road toll are is not related to
the toll booths on the turnpike system
which are operated by the Department of
Transportation
so I just want to give you an idea of
how many licensees we have we have about
180 motor fuel distributors
70 motor fuel transporter license and
approximately I'll round it off to 1800
international field tax agreement
licensees and we also have about 246 oil
discharge and Pollution Control
licensees
uh the oil discharge Pollution Control
licensees we actually collect the
environmental fees for the cleanup funds
for Department of Environmental Services
while we kind of do that in in
conjunction with collecting the fuel tax
um
you turn over to the page seven I just
this is kind of a
a draw kind of a spreadsheet on how the
Tax Works uh in New Hampshire appointed
taxation for motor fuels uh is a
distributor so those 180 Distributors
that I mentioned on the previous page
collect the bulk of the fuel tax so what
happens is uh most of the fields coming
in the State uh to uh barge fuel tank
farms uh most of our gasoline actually
comes in by truck out of Boston or the
Portland area
and then that goes to the terminal
the terminals go down
to a truck and then the truck delivers
it so the difference with us is uh our
tax is actually imposed right before it
goes into retail station so that when
you actually purchase your uh
purchase your fuel at the retail station
the taxes are already included
and if you turn to page eight uh just
put some together some factors uh
impacting estimates for road toll
talk a little bit about price
after reaching a high of almost five
dollars a gallon on June of 22 gas
prices have declined to stabilized
according to AAA the average price per
gallon in New Hampshire uh as of 124 is
three dollars and 32 cents a gallon this
is up fives about five cents from last
year's average of uh 320 327.
uh the U.S Energy Information forecast
motor gasoline prices that declined to
330 a gallon in 2023 and 310 a gallon in
2024.
uh the energy uh the Energy Information
Administration also expects crude oil
prices to average out about 83 dollars a
barrel in both 2023 and fall to 78
dollars a barrel in uh 2024. I want to
talk a little bit about the weather
because that weather has an impact on
our revenues also so if you've got like
a dry dry sum isn't snow we went there's
actually increases tourism in New
Hampshire and result in increased fuel
consumption
uh lack of snow until the other day
in a warm temperatures Place pressure on
the fuel consumption in the winter I
think you might see revenues go up a
little bit now that we got some more
snow
uh as far as the economy Youth
Department of Commerce Bureau of
economic analysis
uh domestic gross product increased at
an average of 3.2 percent in the third
quarter of 2022 in the second quarter of
2022 the real uh gross domestic product
decreased at a rate of about 0.6 percent
uh the U.S Bureau of Labor Statistics
reported that on January 12th that the
Consumer Price Index for all items Rose
about six and a half percent from
December 2021 to December 2022 The cpin
increased by seven percent between
December 2020 and December 2021
and now I'm going to turn it back over
to director LaVoy
so those three factors are really
critical and one doesn't have any real
priority over the other so typically if
we see low prices the economy is doing
well and the weather's great
we've got a lot of consumption of fuel
in the state a lot of Tourism dollars
are coming in people are coming up into
the state if one of those is off we
start to see a decline it could be price
it but the weather's great but the price
is making people change their behaviors
it could be the weather because people
then aren't going to to come up for
skiing they're not going to come up to
the Lakes if it's been raining the
entire time during the summer so right
now we've got downward pressure really
from all of those factors that being
said we're not seeing a huge decrease in
fuel consumption we're still recovering
somewhat from the decline from covid and
our projections as you can see really
reflect conservative estimate that we're
going to continue to get better even
though there's downward pressure people
are still visiting the state they're
still consuming fuel so in fiscal year
22 we collected 124 million in Road till
revenues which was two percent more than
our plan and we're projecting to collect
124.3 million in revenues which is 2.5
million more than our plan for FY 23.
and FY 24 and 25 we're assuming an
increase of half a percent in each year
due to that downward pressure that we
just talked about and kind of the slow
and steady recovery to to pre-covered
consumption levels
any questions on road toll before we
move on
that's a great idea why don't we start
at this end of the room we'll work our
way around representative Rochford
thank you madam sure on page five
the highway fund just goes back there uh
said fiscal year 22 your Highway fund
Revenue was up
by 7 million 7.4 million dollars and
you're projecting it to actually be down
uh for fiscal year 23.
um
can you just
get into a little bit why you you know
why why you and maybe you did through
those three points that you just
discussed but a little more detail would
be helpful as far as why we're
projecting
um the revenue to be two percent less
than than the plan
and so there's a number of factors there
some some of them are DMV related
revenues which we'll get into in the
next section
um in the DMV cycle we didn't see a
significant decline in DMV related
revenues due to covid because people
still need to register their vehicles
Drive their vehicles have access across
the state but there was some pent-up
demand that we experienced an increase
that was higher than expected in 22 and
so we expect 23 to level off slightly
and be be back to the normal expected
Revenue collections
I also like to mention it's not having a
real significant impact but as warm more
electric vehicles and these new heights
going to start affecting the road so a
little bit every year it's not a Major
Impact yet but I was looking at some of
the numbers in uh we're up over five to
six thousand electric vehicles
registered in the state previous year it
was like
I want to say between four and five so
it's going up it's it's going up consist
consistently every year for more and
more electric vehicles are being
registered
representative Phyllis thank you madam
chair
um so this is gas tax money but the
titles call it toll road tolls so what
happens to the money that's actually
um either paid at the toll booth or or
from the transponders
registered by the Department of
Transportation okay speaking after we do
okay thank you and in New Hampshire
what's unique is the um it's it's a road
toll for the use of New Hampshire roads
as opposed to a tax applied to the sale
of gasoline and so we do have refunds
for individuals who are putting gasoline
in their vehicles or engines that are
not using the roads not using the ways
of the state and that's why it's a toll
as opposed to a tax but the reality is
it's the equivalent of a gas tax from
other states
right so if you have a boat and you put
fuel in it you can get a refund on that
tax
okay working around the room
representative Olney
on page seven
is when your truck gets to the retail
outlet yes and you measure it based on
the
the measuring devices of that retail
outlet
so that's kind of a it's two there's
actually a medium when it comes off the
truck
and there's also a Vita root usually
that the retail stations that can tell
how much is going in the tank to keep
track of inventory but specific the
taxes the person actually paying the tax
is the distributor the truck you know
the distributor that's uh hide the truck
to deliver to the retail station
so typically what will happen is the uh
when the retail pays for the price per
gallon uh that that New Hampshire tax
rate is incorporated into that price
sometimes they'll break it up and show
it but
typically that the price is incorporated
into the price per gallon when they sell
it to the retail
so if I could follow up follow up I am
asking this is that a fair number of
years back now on the on
Department of Agriculture weights and
measures group on managed to convince
the legislature to that it was a
conflict of interest on
for the consumer by that
the owners of the gas stations or
managers on
hired the people that checked the
accuracy of those meters
and they collected the data for I think
it was 14 months before another bill
came in and they got closed down
and what they found was that the large
stations were
um
providing less gas than what on they
said they were providing and the small
mom-and-pop stations were providing more
gas
on is there a question there yes the
question is
um
who who inspects these meters
that are tax is based on
I'm not an expert in that but I do know
that the program isn't administered by
the Department of Agriculture awaits and
measures Bureau it's still administered
by them
um I think it'd probably be better to
talk to them with direct directly to get
better information but I'm pretty sure
that uh people go in there and they take
you know they license these people to go
out and inspect the pumps but I I would
probably defer to them to get a better
explanation thank you they told us that
on
I was there when they they passed the
bill that was going to remove that
Authority so
okay other questions yes representative
Platt I just found what the fee was 222.
uh yeah and you see the 50 million
dollar deficit uh that you're not
covering uh the cost of uh you need 50
million more you're taking from the
general fund is that right I'll defread
well Steve that was that was last
biennium okay to make last biennium's
budget uh balance through the highway
fund all right so my mass tells me it
would have to be 31 cents
rather than 20 to 222 I'm not suggesting
that because the whole infrastructure is
changing with more electric and hybrid
vehicles but that's what would have to
be to break even
in that root range there's a number of
approaches so that if you're looking to
only capture the deficit through the
road toll
um then then you would need to increase
increase the gas tax but there's also
fees that from the DMV that support the
highway fund and and um to your point
and to what Scott had mentioned the EV
uh electric vehicles hybrid vehicles
um determining if there's a way that
they can contribute to the road toll
um based on their usage as well and just
to add to that uh I close my office
collects approximately I want to say
about 800 to 20 820 million gallons
versus uh somewhere in that rate so
basically for every penny of the road
toll a penny will bring in just over
eight million dollars with 15 uh 12
percent of that going back to the local
cities and towns in Ohio highway 8.
any other questions representative all
me thank you this is a very uh different
question
um I was trying to estimate how much it
would cost to rebuild our roads inside
of my homeowners complex which I run and
I found a federal index in the
department of highways which uh for
quite a few years now has been
estimating the average cost of
rebuilding
roads and and bridges
at various levels do you use that at all
to
or is that into that would be in in the
Department of Transportation sorry yes
you collect the money and they and they
build the rules right right sorry wrong
Department
yeah
yes
thank you
um
yeah I'm interested in uh information
about the electric vehicle or more
broadly the more efficient hybrid to
electric vehicle movement that's
happening in our vehicles and you
mentioned that as a a coming factor and
I'm sure that you've done a fair amount
of analysis on this partly in response
to legislation that
uh seeks to find some way of capturing
the wear and tear that those vehicles
are responsible for so I'm wondering if
you have report a report on this issue
that would be easy for you to provide to
this committee so we can get a sort of
better handle on where this might be
going
representative Majors had done numerous
studies but I can tell you that
approximately the average citizen pays
about
108 to 115 dollars a year in road toll
so if somebody has a purely electric
vehicle
that'd be about the month if if that was
the equivalent if they paid the
equivalent amounts it's about 108 to 115
volts per vehicle
and we'll be looking just to follow up
just
comment on that we'll we'll be losing
that
each time an electric vehicle replaces a
regular vehicle yeah because the
electric vehicle is not using a
petroleum-based product to fill up it
obviously using electric
ity yeah thank you do we have any idea
at what rate that degradation is
happening or are you saying we should
check with
Dot
like how how how many people are we
losing you know to electric vehicles I
mean so the this is where it gets really
challenging because Scott mentioned in
the state of New Hampshire there was
what four thousand well right now
looking at the numbers I got it from DMV
because I was doing an analysis for
another build but for it's a little it's
getting close to 6 000 registered okay
two five and six thousand so close to
six thousand in New Hampshire
um but a lot of our vehicle traffic is
from out of state and so that's where
some of the challenges come in the the
6000 is not going to help us uh how do
we capture
um capture the people who are visiting
and making sure that that those gasoline
collection losses are recovered somehow
right thank you uh let me go to
representative roachford thank you Mr
chair so with that could you just I mean
conceivably
we could study we know how many are in
state we know it's about 120 115 a year
I mean it's a fairly easy number to
to to find out we could add that to like
a registration fee well the
someone who registers electric vehicle
you'd pay an extra X number of dollars
per year there's been there's been
several bills over the last you know
three to five years that have taken
approaches similar to that
um factoring in a full EV versus a
hybrid and and prorating those amounts
um and uh that's that that's one
approach absolutely
yes there have been a number of bills I
don't think any one of them has uh stuck
yet so but uh we certainly are trending
towards the fact that we do need to do
something representative Almy yeah just
to add on to that first on I've had a
hybrid for a long time it used to get 35
miles per gallon in the winter it's now
getting about 40. I don't know if that's
because the winters are warmer but on so
it's getting about twice what what our
expectations used to be for what a car
did
um and it's just a hybrid so then there
are a lot more hybrids than there are
electric vehicles on the road at this
point
um but on
the the other piece of that
was on there is a commission which is
being reestablished which on
ended last year too quickly on and to
finish doing the analyzes about
representative Majors work and hopefully
finally come up with some kind of
compromise between Public Works and
the legislature that's that's a would
you believe question okay I believe
question representative Aras
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question so is there a possibility of
we just uh putting a toll on the cars
coming in from out of state
especially electric vehicles I mean
we're we're we're collecting a higher
toll
full premature but uh
the department uh all the states and uh
kind of a Canadian frog
yeah
the 48
Continental contiguous states and
Canadian provinces belong to a program
called the international fuel tax
agreement
and right now if your vehicle's over 26
000 pounds like a truck commercial
trucks they have to report all that
where they purchase all their fuel and
where they drive they so our office
takes all that information and puts it
through the system and figures out how
you know what we go to the other states
with the other States owe to us so the
Canadian provinces and I know that I'm
very active in that I'm currently on the
Board of Trustees for that organization
and after trying to look at a way to
take the if the model and bring it down
to passenger vehicles but it's still
very premature right now but because you
got other issues like for example uh
you got a lot of people that live in New
Hampshire travel to Boston every day and
vice versa you got a ton of people in
Massachusetts coming up here to stay for
the weekend how do we capture the
revenue on those Vehicles when they come
from out of state or vice versa how does
Massachusetts get their fish here for
the people commuting down the Boston
area every day to work
yes
um any any other questions
okay seeing none we will continue
in the interest of time
um I'll move rather quickly through the
next section but please stop me at any
point if you have any questions so DMV
fees we talked about this a little bit
already
DMV revenues that are collected uh don't
experience a lot of change they're
rather inelastic to price demand because
we're we're a rural State there aren't a
lot of public uh Transportation options
for us people need vehicles to obtain
goods and services and get to where they
need to vehicle sales have been impacted
due to lack of inventory over the last
several years
we're starting to see inventory levels
um
be replenished so we should see some
increased automobile sales over the next
six to 12 months and there is some
pent-up demand for vehicle purchases and
so we think that's going to offset
downward pressure from The increased
pricing that we've seen and we spoke
about earlier so we're expecting a
slight positive impact on registration's
title and inspection revenues moving
forward so on page 11 Motor Vehicle
Registration Revenue
um in FY 22 we collected 90 million
dollars which was 1.8 million over plan
and 23 we're projecting to collect 89.2
million which is 900 000 over plan and
we're projecting to increase those
revenues in 24 and 25 by about a half a
percent so 89.7 and 90.1 million
respectively and these are the
registration fees that are collected on
the state side of the equation there's
still the local portion that's collected
but this is the state share those go
directly into the highway fund
page 12 motor vehicle operators this is
these are your licenses the key piece
here to understand is that there's a
five-year dip based on when the licenses
uh changed from a four-year to a
five-year license and so you see that in
FY 16 and an FY 21 and you can see that
dip over time is leveling off we're
projecting that that dip will be
resolved by 2035
and so we will see that dip the next dip
will occur in fiscal year 26. the other
piece to understand is the real ID
driver license requirements which keep
getting delayed the most recent date is
May 7th of 2025 and that's at that time
a real ID will be required for any
domestic air travel or to enter secure
Federal facilities and so we do think
that as that date gets closer we have
some people who will be transitioning to
the real ID piece so those
considerations have been factored in and
we're projecting just under 15 million
to be collected in the next uh in 23 24
and 25.
on page 13 motor vehicle title revenues
again relatively consistent across the
board
we've got some slight increases that
we're projecting in 24 and 25 a two
percent increase and that's because of
what we spoke about earlier with some
inventories finally coming to be
available for people to purchase and so
there may be some new title processing
that will be done associated with those
with those transactions
page 14 Motor Vehicle Inspection Revenue
another area that's that that's
relatively consistent
um we collect four million in one year
3.9 in the next that's because of this
station fee the inspection station fee
uh it's a two-year fee that's collected
and so you see that reflected in in the
revenues
um throughout so no real changes here
um the number of stations hasn't
increased dramatically and the number of
inspections hasn't either
on page 15 this is the miscellaneous
motor vehicle fees
um what sticks out what you'll see is in
starting in fiscal year 20 The Plea by
mail revenues which used to go to the
general fund are now being recorded in
the highway fund and so that's helping
to address some of that structural
deficit that we talked about
and in in general we don't see any
significant Revenue growth opportunities
here this is going to be Hold the Line
similar collections that we've seen
um coming out of covid where we'll have
about 5.9 million in plea by mail about
5.6 million in judicial motor vehicle
fines collected by the judicial branch
and then other motor vehicle fees of
about 3.9 3.8 million
uh and then lastly on page 17 uh is a
brief summary of our general funds can I
stop you for one second you have a
question uh representative almond uh
just very briefly play by mail and also
what the courts uh have to adjudicate on
and I've under for a long time we've
been being told
uh the state police are slowing down on
tickets because it's a bad year and
people and they're they don't want to
hurt people or something like that and
then they'll speed up again in doing
tickets is that what happened in
that they just dissect the state police
were out there a lot more because
people had been misbehaving in the
pandemic yeah so um in 21 you started to
see an increase in motor vehicle traffic
coming out of the pandemic so a lot of
people who were working from home
quarantined those scenarios started to
decline and so there was an uptick in
traffic and so you saw an uptick in
enforcement activities as well there is
always that that question about
um you know when the economic conditions
are are challenging the courts the
judges everyone involved sometimes will
reduce penalties reduce fines and so
there's some of that that likely may be
going on but there's no way for us to
really capture that level of information
or just let them go with a warning
do you push them
do we push them
to give more tickets
uh no no
little outside the purview
any other questions
okay let's continue
and so for General funds uh
again this is really more for
informational purposes uh not very much
about 8 million that we collect each
year it's gone down over time primarily
because certain functions have
transitioned out of the Department of
Safety into other areas the biggest one
being the mechanical licensing function
which is uh now at the office of
professional licensure and certification
and so those revenues traveled with that
function as well
um
page 18 provides a little bit of summary
on the key areas the initial license and
vanity plate fees that are collected
those revenues are con projected to
remain consistent the penalty assessment
that's levied at the courts that's a two
dollars or twenty four percent whichever
is greater on each finer penalty so
we're showing the general fund portion
there but there's revenues that support
the victims assistance fund and then the
judicial branch Information Technology
fund and then permits and Licensing has
decreased steadily over time that's a
hundred dollars for non-resident pistol
license fees which was a significant
Revenue Source but as reciprocity a lot
of individuals who have the ability to
get an out-of-state permit have already
received it and so we're seeing demand
for that continue to decline over time
uh and on the very last page we have a
summary of the highway fund revenues uh
over the last 10 years by Source type
um I know that the committee often likes
to work from documents like this so
that's for your use moving forward
I'm happy to answer any additional
questions
thank you very much
representative Platt
new Merchant fees is that something you
have the ability to set such as Affinity
plate fee or is that incorporated into
law
um it depends on the fee itself so the
vanity plate fees are in statute there's
some fees that are in administrative
rule
um so whether it's administrative rule
or statute there's always involvement of
the legislature
representative roachford yes thank you
um
just to go back here a little bit to
understand a little bit about the
department uh
well first of all I'm happy to give
warnings out around Plymouth exit 25 so
I'll take those warnings every time they
give them to me so
so you can pass that along keep doing
keep up the good work
um just I just want to understand uh so
I again this is very a rudimentary
question
understanding that uh your department is
um
Motor Vehicles Administration State
Police Homeland Security and then I'm
looking back on five as far as the the
the total Highway fund revenues remain
relatively fat flat leading to a
structural deficit within the highway
fund due to regular increases associated
in the costs associated with road
maintenance so are you guys doing the
road maintenance or the Department of
Transportation that's that's the
Department of Transportation okay and so
um we are the revenue collection agency
okay okay and the Department of
Transportation and the department of
safety both uh receive Appropriations so
it flows through you correct okay thank
you
any other questions
saying none thank you very much thank
you thank you
foreign
we'll now move on to the Department of
Transportation
and we have
with us today looks like William Cass
I don't know if
Danielle
Chardonnay and Kathleen Mulcahy
yeah
I don't see it yeah
good afternoon gentlemen if you would uh
introduce yourselves
good afternoon thank you for having us I
didn't know if you'd need a break or
anything in between but uh
um so uh my name is Bill Cass I'm a
recently appointed commissioner for the
Department of Transportation with me
today I have my uh assistant
commissioner Dave rodrigue uh uh and my
Deputy Commissioner Andre Brier
um you have the presentation we're kind
of going to go over a little bit of an
orientation an overview of the D.O.T and
a little discussion of the very small
amount of Highway fund Revenue that that
the dot collects uh I just heard dos and
Steve talk about the that they are the
um
they are they are the ones that collect
the revenue and um
both dos and Dot uh have Appropriations
out of the highway fund so with that um
I'll just kind of Step through this very
quickly if that's okay with you
um
so on the first page is our mission and
purpose statement that Transportation
excellence
and enhancing the quality of life in New
Hampshire that's our that's our mission
uh and the purpose is to implement and
Implement that through all of we do all
we do
um
we think transportation is essential to
the state's Economic Development and we
strive to address that in our and our
mission statement through
well-maintained efficient reliable and
seamless interstate and interest
intrastate connectivity and
transportation systems
so we're organized on slide
um
slide two not counting the cover page
slide two is a very high level overview
of our organizational structure
so in our Commissioner's Office it's
myself and the two
other Commissioners assistant and Deputy
Commissioner we oversee five divisions
within the department so the assistant
commissioner Dave to my left generally
oversees all of the operational aspects
that's uh project development the group
that administers and does all the
transportation projects
plans builds designs constructs
requires the right-of-way and things
like that as well as all of the
operational aspects in maintaining the
um the highway and I see it's starting
to snow now so our folks will be out all
night tonight
um taking care of maintaining the
highways on the administration side on
the deputy commission aside he oversees
a lot of the uh more kind of the Chief
Financial Officer and overseeing
um you know kind of the non-highway
infrastructure so he's overseas Finance
all the policy and administration HR and
some of our labor compliance bureaus as
well as the division of Aeronautics Rail
and Transit
um
so some very quick facts just to give a
quick size and uh overview of the dot so
we have about 1650
permanent positions
um
we maintain and oversee 21 about 2150
2159 State Bridges we've talked a lot
about redless bridges which are
structurally deficient Bridges and that
redless count is at 114.
um that number has been driven down over
the years we continue to focus our
efforts on preservation and maintenance
of the existing infrastructures first
and that red list Bridge number
is indicative of of that as we continue
to drive that number down we also have
Administration in a way over the
approximately 1700 Municipal Bridges
even though those are Town owned Bridges
uh the state of New Hampshire State you
know the New Hampshire dot is
responsible for inspecting all of the
bridges in the state so all of the state
and all of the municipal Bridges get
inspected by dot Personnel usually twice
a year I mean usually once every two
years a regular closed captioning not
available
safe and reliable we oversee and
maintain about 4 600 Centerline miles of
roadway and along that roadway or a
hundred thousand signs about 68 million
feet of Lane striping that we try to get
to each and every year
440 traffic signals and 550 traffic
beacons
we also have oversight of 195 194 miles
of active state-owned Rail lines that's
a little bit of a misnomer Andre may hit
on some of the numbers there are
a lot of miles of uh I think close to
250 miles or so of of inactive
state-owned railroad lines that are that
are still under our purview as well too
we oversee
um
funding and compliance at 25 publicly
accessible airports and 11 public
transit systems that funding comes
through the dot rfta funding that goes
to those agencies
so on slide four as a very high level
snapshot of our budget size and just
general overview so our FY 22
expenditures was close to 600 million
dollars
we divide our budget into kind of two
halves the municipal Aid and
construction costs were about 305
million dollars of that of that budget
Municipal Aid and construction is all of
our construction programs and all of the
money that flows through dot to the
municipalities that's the block grant
Aid some of the federal aid that comes
through us to municipalities for their
projects things like that so we so we
kind of blocked that out separately
because a lot of that is flowed through
uh money in terms of Grants and other
things to municipalities as well as our
overall construction program the other
part of our budget to 282 million
dollars there designated in the pie
piece in Orange is our operating cost
that's the operating budget of the
department that's largely the uh the
personnel and uh equipment and
commodities the salt and everything that
that's needed to run and maintain the
department
so if you look at our budget it is a
multi-funded through a variety of of
funds and the breakdown is there in
terms of percentages but our overall
budget is funded by you know the highway
fund federal funds Turnpike funds other
funds and a very small percentage of
General funds that support the division
of Aeronautics Rail and Transit the bulk
of our operating budget I will say
because we're in uh budget season the
bulk of our operating budget is funded
through the highway fund bulk of our uh
Municipal High Municipal Aid and
construction is uh leans higher toward
the toward the federal funds
so with that
um I'll have um Dave just go over some
uh quick bullets a little bit of the
couple of Divisions onto his purview and
then uh have Andre do the same and he'll
get into some of the finances that that
uh
some of the finances on the highway fund
and the small amount of Highway fund
Revenue that the dot collects so
Dave oh sorry
so good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee thank you for
taking time to hear from us today
um I will touch briefly on my
responsibilities as the assistant
commissioner and the chief engineer for
the Department of Transportation so
under under the assistant commissioner
is basically two divisions the division
of project development project
development includes our Highway design
Bureau that
um designs the projects that that we
advertise it also includes our project
managers that set up the project
schedules and funding and keep track of
them through the 10-year plan process in
the interaction with the communities as
the project said designed and developed
project development also includes at
Bureau bridge design bridge design
obviously designs uh the bridges that we
have they also oversee the the bridge
inspection section that inspects a
bridge Bridges as Bill described and
keeps the records that we report to
Federal Highway and the FEDS on US state
Bridges and the condition of our bridges
project development includes the Bureau
of Construction Construction oversees
our contracts once a project is designed
and advertised and a private contractor
builds a construction folks oversee that
construction they paid the contractor
and make sure that the work is done
according to the plans and
specifications and solve the day-to-day
problems that come up in executing a
large complex construction project we
have the Bureau of right-of-way that
deals with all our land purchases and
manages some of the properties that we
own our Bureau of environment to make
sure that as we design projects we
design them according to environmental
regulations and then follow through
construction and operations and
maintenance to make sure that we're
environmentally compliant we also have a
bureau of planning and Community
Assistance who helps us put together the
10-year plan who helps to also provide
support to the communities and so forth
and oversee municipally managed projects
and that Bureau of materials and
research make sure that all our
specifications for materials and
supplies that go into our projects meet
requirements and are up to Snuff as as
well the project development Bureau or
division puts together our 10-year
Transportation plan that's updated every
two years and we administer about 225
million dollars worth of federal funds
using construction projects every year
in fiscal year 22 we had 57 new
construction cut contracts and went out
to bid in our Bureau of construction
over saw 84 active construction projects
with a total value of 750 million
dollars
fiscal year 22 we advertise 233 million
dollars worth of projects
moving over to our division of
operations
um operations is responsible for
operations and maintenance of our
transportation system we do that with
six bureaus
um the first is a bureau of Highway
Maintenance Highway Maintenance is
Statewide we have six Highway
Maintenance districts all responsible
for a portion of the state
um those are largely the the folks who
will be out plowing snow tonight
interestingly
um we plow snow with about half of our
people and vehicles in about half
contract rented
um vehicles and and people as well so
when you see us out there working it's
not just us we have great Partnerships
um with contractors who help us get that
work done
we have 87 Patrol sections Statewide it
sounds like a lot but that's one Patrol
section for about every 2.6 town so it's
really spread out
um pretty well and that's why we're
successful because we have that logistic
distribution across the state
um Highway Maintenance also responds to
emergency events
um and does the tree trimming the mowing
the cleanup the drainage the ditching
and everything during the summer
other operations Bureau includes the
Bureau of traffic they do all our line
striping take care about traffic signals
and signs they also do our traffic
counting keeping track of volumes they
have a traffic research section
um they look at the traffic impact
studies for our major
developments that get built and impact
the transportation system uh Bureau of
bridge maintenance we have 12 Crews
um one Crews responsible for the lip
Bridges and Portsmouth the remaining 11
work around the state maintaining and
preserving our bridges washing the
bridges in the spring and keeping them
in good condition
Mechanical Services overseas a fleet
worth about a hundred ten million
dollars and keeps that going the the
vast majority of that flea is the plow
trucks
um that serve dual purpose they plow
snow in the winter and they haul
material in the summer
we run a fuel distribution system as
well and we have our transportation
systems management and operations Bureau
that helps to monitor what's going on
the roadway and provide Travelers
real-time information
in addition we have our Bureau of
turnpikes our Turnpike system is an
enterprise system so all the funds
collected on the turnpike stay on the
turnpike in fiscal year 22 we collected
about 123 million dollars of toll
revenue and we project in 2024 to
collect about 125 million in in 2025
about
144 million dollars
I'm gonna turn things over now to Andre
thank you Dave and thank you uh Mr
chairman members of the committee I'm
Andre Briere I've been Deputy uh here at
dot for a little over a year and a half
now I spent most of my career in the U.S
Air Force as a retired Colonel spent
most of that time as a as a pilot but
also a good portion in transportation
leadership so uh
a lot of that comes in handy uh here at
dot I'll just walk you briefly through
my portfolios which include as the
commissioner said Aviation rail Transit
as well as finance and administration on
the Aeronautics side as the commissioner
mentioned we have 25 open to the public
airports in New Hampshire of those 12
are federally funded we act as a
pass-through for a lot of these funds
we're one of 10 states that are what
what are called block grant States so
what that really means is we have
additional authorities and permissions
from the U.S Department of
Transportation to act as proxies when
we're providing funding to these
airports that's something that that's a
privilege we enjoy and we work very
closely with our FAA office in Boston as
we execute that plan three of those
airports are commercial uh as as you
would know Manchester Portsmouth peas
and Lebanon
um for the airports uh that we have
opened the public that are not federally
funded uh what we do and you can see at
the bottom of that Aeronautics section
we take in about 470
000 or so in aviation registration fees
that funding goes right to our
operations and also we use that to fund
projects that are non uh federally
funded airports
one thing that's not on here as well in
the uh on the Aeronautics side is our
growing and uh very uh lean and
efficient uas programs that's uas drones
we at dot take pictures of projects not
people so all of our drones are aimed at
uh our construction projects and also a
Disaster Response we're very proud of
how that program's developing it's a lot
cheaper for the Department to run it
ourselves versus Contracting that out
which comes at a premium these days and
we have an excellent drone pilot program
we're developing more operators all the
time on the rail side uh we do manage
about 194 little little south of 2000 or
um miles of rail
far more abandoned rail line so what we
do with that is that's converted into
rail trails in some cases it's also
leased out to commercial operators that
do things like rail bikes that you may
be familiar with in Laconia or near here
in Concord
but we uh we're developing additional
uses for that those corridors all the
time the reason we maintain them is uh
to preserve them for future use is if it
sometime down the road any decision is
made to revive rail on those routes
uh finally on this slide is our public
transit we have 11 local public transit
providers who we work very closely with
um we have excellent Partnerships with
companies like coast and Concord Coach
Boston Express Etc
uh the big point I want to make on this
section is that uh
as you may be familiar uh post 2020
there's been evolving commuting patterns
what we're seeing among our Transit
providers is a slow return to pre-2020
levels that's a little patchy you see
Peaks very close to normal Tuesdays
through through Thursdays slightly
different but we continue to track
improving uh improving revenues on that
side
on the administration uh side our
executive office does what what all
departments Executives offices do make
sure we utilize the funds distributed
and granted by this body in the most
efficient way possible our finance team
is excellent they deal with a lot of
different colors of money
um and their
they have ever uh more efficient
processes to do that we have a new
Director of Finance sitting behind us
here Danielle chandanae and she is a
really excellent asset to the department
and is doing a wonderful job at that on
the policy Administration side as the
commissioner mentioned I also oversee HR
internal audit health and safety Federal
compliance all those things we need to
do to make sure we can spend our federal
funds
so the next slide is really uh I think I
don't want to reiterate what Mr Lavoy
probably told you but just to make the
point that although the highway fund is
traditionally associated with DOT as you
heard from him it is not the Department
of Transportation and we don't collect
most funds that go into the highway fund
and that's comprised of the gas gas and
road toll registration fees Etc we also
uh the highway fund is also where we uh
wear proceeds from tiffia Garvey bonds
are deposited it is the primary source
of funding for our operating budget as
commissioner Cass mentioned
and the the revenues go to dot safety
judicial branch and Justice the majority
of it does come to Dot and that's what
we use for our projects and maintenance
of of our transportation system
the next slide is addresses a question
we were
um asked to to address uh in this body
and that is the highway fund revenues
that we actually collect now it's a very
very small sliver of the overall Highway
fund but we do collect annually
um
what we budget at about two hundred
thousand dollars you can see on the
bottom chart that that does vary year to
year but there are four main categories
uh of funds that that
flow through us into the highway fund
that's the highway portion of surplus
property sales that the department has
acquired over the years and then we
liquidate over time as as they're not
needed for Highway purposes Surplus
equipment
um and end of useful life type equipment
sign advertising junkyard licenses court
fees things like that it's a very small
portion of the highway fund but it does
flow through us into the into the fund
so with that I will pass it to
commissioner Cass unless there are any
questions on my portfolio
um I I don't know
um
was there a question I'll tell you
yes
I can see your hands yeah representative
Southworth would like a question thank
you
thank you
um I live near the lime bridge in the
summer so I'm very glad that it's been
moved up on your red list but in part of
the discussion I believe it was home for
your department it was shared that it's
getting very hard to put these type of
bridges out to Bid And if that was you
know causing a challenge but I didn't
know if that's affecting you or not but
that's what was stated in the report
yeah is that the lime theft food Bridge
yes
um
yeah um and I'll just digress for a
minute uh Madam chair the rest of the
presentation is kind of uh what we had
done for our introductory budget
presentation just some of the challenges
and stuff I don't know if that's
appropriate for this body or or I'm
happy to go through it but it does
address a little bit of uh your question
one of the one of the issues
um that is that that we do highlight on
on the issues and challenges is is
inflation uh and increasing labor and
material costs so what your um
referring to is is directly related to
that to that issue so when we had
advertised the line Thetford Bridge
originally uh we got no no bidders and
we had some
construction requirements and some
schedule requirements that in a debrief
with the construction industry we found
out that was fairly onerous and and it
really deterred uh some some contractors
from from bidding on the on the project
we changed some of those uh requirements
and and if you're from the area you know
some of the consternation that that that
I'm well aware that that created but um
you know we had to make those
um changes to the construction
requirements and the construction
schedule lengthening it out a little bit
and we received three bidders the bids
did come in
um higher than our estimate so it is it
is a challenge but it's directly related
to difficulties that you refer to are
directly related to the inflationary
costs as well as
um you know the uh increasingly tight
labor market and trying to find uh
workers there so so thank you so it's
really applies to the whole big picture
the trouble we're having there yes thank
you yes exactly representative Ames has
a question and then let's talk where we
are and what time it is and what we need
to do okay thanks go ahead please oh
okay thank you
um yeah when the Liquor Commission was
here well we talked a little bit about
struggles they're having with uh
retention of employees
you have a lot of employees I wonder uh
how you're faring in in this regard
whether this is a a problem that you're
on top of and I'm sure you're on top of
it but uh you know that it's going all
right or it's going south
we're on top of it to the degree that
we're we're managing it I don't have any
any any any
great Solutions uh but the the
challenges that you said liquor had had
referred to I mean we're facing those it
is one of these challenges that I've
highlighted here
um we've had historically High
um we've had historically High vacancy
rates
um upwards of uh department-wide around
25 so that's one in every four positions
being vacant and certain bureaus uh you
know
um have have higher vacancy rates
um
some of our design bureaus are are
facing you know 40 to 50 vacancy rates
hiring Engineers
um and some of our um I think it was
Bridge maintenance in particular had uh
around 30 to 35 vacancy rates at one
point so it is a challenge one of the
things that the legislature or or
through the governor's office and the
governor and Council and fiscal
committee we did in the fall there was
approval for a um winter maintenance
um
incentive bonus retention bonus of five
thousand dollars for the season so we
were seeing a continually climbing uh
vacancy rate
um it seemed to stem the tide I don't
know if that five thousand dollar bonus
had
um
necessarily brought more people in but
at least for the time being seem to
level off the um The Exodus and our
vacancy rate has been holding steady
about that
uh it also was a very needed uh uh boost
for the morale uh recognition of their
hard work and efforts and recognition
that that they uh
um that their compensation is is
challenging so
thank you for the answer that's very
helpful sure
we all love getting these agency
presentations because we like meeting
you and finding about what you do we
like to hear about your problems and
opportunities but we do have to stay a
little bit focused on the revenue side
and of course we have a schedule to
comply with so I don't know if you had
any more to talk about revenues right
now or what where you are in the
presentation I apologize that's exactly
where we were like like I said we we've
mentioned a few times I I thought the
department of safety did an excellent
presentation on on the bulk of the
revenue and the highway fund we have a
very very small it's fairly kind of
miscellaneous type of type of stuff but
we wanted to just have that information
so well maybe we can have you come back
but we really are interested and we
appreciate everything that you do very
very much and then you know we'll be
going back to do actually pen to paper
on Revenue estimates so if we need you
hopefully we can call you sure okay
great thank you so much you know we
weren't asked but Dave did bring up the
uh the the turnpike Revenue projections
as well oh great bottom line wonderful
and that's all in this pack package uh
the the yeah he mentioned verbally the
we didn't include but the um
yeah the 24 and 25 the 24 projections
for revenue is uh 125 million dollars in
the 2025 uh is 144 million dollars so
generally level but then ticking up
um as um we look toward the end of the
buyer excellent and I'm looking at Chris
Shea you're you've got notes on that for
the spreadsheet we should provide an
update or however you want to get that
oh right that's good point yeah okay
okay great thank you so much really
appreciate you you're welcome thank you
all very much we appreciate it
okay next up we have Barry Glennon from
the Securities Bureau
good afternoon Madam chair uh Barry
Glennon uh the director with the New
Hampshire Bureau of Securities
regulation uh thank you very much for uh
inviting me uh here this afternoon to
speak to you about the bureau and more
specifically uh uh our Revenue Uh
current revenue and projected Revenue
our Revenue pales in comparison to the
previous uh presenters uh however uh you
know still
a significant contribution in terms of
Revenue to the general fund just to
briefly uh review if I may as Chris has
just distributed a very small packet uh
describing the bureau we are a division
of the Secretary of State's office and
um uh that is in addition to
corporations and uh Vital Records I see
representative Bolton here a former
registrar and
um so I'd like to if I could just
briefly review the role of the bureau
and some of it's a major functions we're
primarily responsible for the regulatory
oversight of broker-dealers and
investment advisors those are
individuals who will buy and sell
Securities on behalf of clients also
provide as the name would imply
investment advice to their clients we
also registered a number of Securities
that are sold in New Hampshire and in
addition to that
provide investor education to New
Hampshire residents through a variety of
outlets or a Civic organizations
continuing education type programs and
then any other form including
presentations to any of your
constituents if you would like us to
present
in addition we also perform regular
in-person audits of firms that are
engaged in security sales we also do
those on an unannounced basis and find
that very effective a significant
portion of our activity is is actually
related to enforcement matters now this
would include
investor fraud unlawful sales practices
in a variety of investor education or
excuse me investor complaints that we
receive throughout the year as you'll
see on page three of the handout this
provides you with a just a brief
snapshot of our licensing activity and
you'll note that as of the end of 12 31
of 2022 we registered 148 620 broker
dealer Representatives that are
authorized to solicit into the state so
New Hampshire really is
an interest for broker-dealers and
investment advisors we are a wealth
Center we have an older population
we have a lot of money actually retirees
in the state and as a result we have
firms you know seeking to do business in
New Hampshire and they certainly do
given that number 2 800 investment
advisors and approximately 5200
investment advisor representatives and
we register 29 000 or thereabouts
various investment products a good
portion of those are Investment Company
products known as otherwise known as
mutual funds approximately fifteen
thousand of those
I would like to point out that the
bureau is self-funded all of our
administrative expenses are paid by the
way of fines and penalties that we
receive through our enforcement actions
uh with that said I would like to direct
your attention really to the last page
which will note the various general fund
Revenue sources and they're really there
are two the first is the broker dealer
an investment advisor licensing fees and
the second is the Securities product
registration fees if I could just
briefly explain as I said broker-dealers
that conduct business in the state are
required to pay an annual registration
fee at the firm level and agents and
then every Securities product depending
upon the product will also pay an annual
fee last year the bureau generated 24
million in firm licensing fees and 23.6
million in Securities project
registration fees
now as you look at that I would just ask
that you not be alarmed by the uh 2023
fiscal year numbers uh that only shows
currently 2.7 million uh in
broker-dealer and investment advisor
fees and that's largely due to the fact
that the majority of those uh fees are
booked during the month of January and
are not yet reflected uh here however I
did take a look prior to coming to the
hearing today and we expect to see at
least 16.2 million to be booked by
month's end and ultimately we project
that out to be 21.2 million for fiscal
year 2023.
on the Securities registration side
those revenues have been relatively
consistent over the past two or three
years however they have not really grown
at the same rate as I've shown you the
past five years they haven't grown at
the same rate as on the licensing side
and I think that this is largely due to
a continued contraction of the mutual
fund industry firms have been looking at
their family of funds and consolidating
and we've seen reduction there however
uh we do anticipate that we will settle
out uh fiscal 2023 at 23.8 million most
of that revenue is booked during the
months of April and May when they all
have to require they're required to
renew by May 1st of of each year so
overall looking at our at our bottom
line the bureau is projecting for fiscal
year 2023 to close at 45 million dollars
which is an increase of 870 000 over
last year or prior year and then similar
growth in 2024 and 2025.
um so that that's what we're currently
showing for existing revenue and what we
see the close of fiscal year and
projected forward be happy to answer any
questions Madam chair
thank you that was wonderful uh
questions around the room yes
representative Schamberg just one
question Madam chair uh on the last
figure you gave you said the 170 000 was
an increase well 24 and 25 beat plus 870
or will it just be recorded
uh 45 million 870 000. it would be uh
showing 870 year over year yeah eight
yes we anticipate yes
representative Ames
thank you
um
with regard to your enforcement
activities
which are significant and uh
I'm wondering about the interface with
the Attorney General's office do you
have your own legal staff that handle
handle that legal work or do you work
with the Attorney General's office uh
yes uh to to both we do work with the
Attorney General's office when we see
that a case elevates from civil to
criminal uh and the criminal
jurisdiction and Authority actually you
know to handle those matters but we do
work very closely with them uh with
respect to your initial uh inquiry
question uh we do have attorneys on
staff this is really highly complex
material uh and it was when it comes to
enforcement actions we're dealing with
uh certainly large firms large law firms
and you know they they just love the
paper us and the administrative process
does involve a series of motions and
hearings and the like so uh it keeps us
busy for certain
thank you
other questions
oh yes representative Janine
this might be thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question this
might be a little bit unrelated but
um I think you're in the right branch of
the state to answer it and that is uh
Bitcoin about a year ago I attempted to
buy some Bitcoin and I wasn't able to it
said New Hampshire you cannot buy
Bitcoin in New Hampshire is that still
true or do you know anything about that
well they were they were firms that I
can't speak with with real precisons
here but as I understand
um uh a year or two back that some of
these entities were seeking licensure
through the New Hampshire banking
Department some of them as money
transmitters which I guess that that
means something in terms of the the type
of activity that they do and they may
characterize themselves as money
transmitters but when in fact many of
them are actually acting as a holding
agent for for Bitcoin some offer to to
buy and sell on behalf of a client uh so
it was I I would have to uh guess if and
I hate to guess but at that point in
time they may have been seeking
licensure and were not yet approved uh
it's still a largely unregulated area
frankly uh and we will see I believe the
the SEC Securities Exchange Commission
and other regulatory boughters maybe the
body's a cftc uh you know may step in
and regulate this space we're all aware
of the more recent activities including
you know FTX uh and some of the turmoil
in the markets uh we have a couple
pending actions right now uh it's it's
an unsettled area and we really just
caution uh folks who are considering
investing that to be careful as far as
who they're doing business with
phone
follow-up but it is legal for a New
Hampshire resident to buy Bitcoin
there's there's no there's nothing on
the books that says it's illegal to kind
of phrase it that way
um however you know we we do you know
caution those uh to just to be mindful
that it is a an unregulated area right
now
um
thank you
any other questions I think we're good
thank you so much thank you madam chair
okay crochet wanna wrap it up and give
us your
the presentation we've been waiting for
all along it's finally here
foreign
while I have all of you
um and before Chris gets started
we will plan on some public hearings
next Tuesday
January 31st
five bills
House Bill 297 houseboat 450 House Bill
House Bill 486 house bill
569. in that order in that order thank
you I also have asked the clerk
450.
-450-288-486-569
Tuesday from 10 to 2 30 ish I've asked
the clerk to also list an executive
session on three bills we initially
heard
so we'll see if we want to take those up
at some point during the day we have the
opportunity that we can that's House
Bill 60 camping fees for non-residents
House Bill 121 worldwide combined
reporting under the BPT and House Bill
145 collections of sales taxes of
foreign jurisdictions
so I just want to give you the heads up
on that
um and I'm sure Chris will talk to you
about our future plans for Revenue
estimates and spreadsheets and all of
that good stuff
yes
yeah we're not going to meet next Monday
January 30th
I believe criminal justice needs the
room okay
okay great go ahead
oh thank you Chris Shea for the record
from the legislative budget Assistance
Office
I just wanted to kind of start with who
I am we did it briefly on the first day
that you met your organization day but
I'm the deputy legislative budget
assistant I am assigned to Ways and
Means to assist you with your revenues
during the budget process as well as
Public Works to help them with the
capital budget so there may be some
times when you're working on revenues
that I got to pull next to the next door
and and see what's going on with capital
budget but we'll try to not do that
um but our office if you did attend the
economic briefing with Mike Kane the LBA
did present he talked about our staffing
structure
so we have in our budget side we have
four analysts that are assigned to the
finance committee and they have various
expertise that they deal with and I just
explained what I did and then Mike is
the sixth person in our office is the
LBA and he kind of oversees all of us to
make sure we do our job and then we have
an admin Pam Ellis who really runs the
office and make sure we do what we need
to do so most of our staff is located on
our audit side and I think represent
Schamberg has kind of hit it at home
with some of the questions earlier
throughout the day and that our office
does audit state agencies we do
Financial audits we do performance
audits we do the Statewide audit so that
we work with KPMG who we contract with
and we assign staff to work with them to
do that Statewide audit which is the act
for that I handed out earlier today
my purpose today right now is uh you
know in the last two weeks you've been
getting bombarded with a ton of
information on the economy on revenues
you know what trends are occurring
and you're probably wondering what am I
supposed to do with all this information
and how do I organize it to meet the end
line or the goal so that's what this
packet is hopefully going to help you
with and I'll start walking you through
that so if you flip the page
you'll see contact information for our
office
under the telephone number you'll see
our website and right beneath that is a
specific link to the revenue documents
so everything you're doing in here I'm
trying to post to the website I say
trying because it may take me a day or
two but every presentation to date is on
our website
and if there's corrections I think
there's two agencies that are going to
correct slides that they had in their
presentations we'll update that and I'll
email the members that here's the
updated version of the slide
there's the contact information for each
of us in the office a phone number and
an email
and then at the bottom of the page
there's links to the Department of
administrative services and revenue
Administration both of those places have
financial information that you may be
interested in with the administrative
Services it's the akfer so the revenue
focus and the revenue plan and that link
would take it to those documents
for the Department of Revenue
Administration it's their annual report
as well as the tax tax expenditure
report which is basically the report
that's done to tell you what kind of
credits we're given in the last I think
they do for five years cycle
so you'll hear things like the carry
credit and how that's at 300 million
that's caught up in the tax expenditure
report you know BPT credits against the
BET
um you know those types of things are
found within that tax expenditure report
so that first page is just a good
reference tool if you have questions
email me call me do whatever you need to
do to get in touch with me I will
respond to you it just may not be
immediately and maybe it may take a few
minutes to get back to you but I will
get back to you
the rest of the document is basically
going to just kind of walk you through
the process that you're going to go
through
so page one is just some assorted
acronyms and terms that you might hear
you know you heard Road told today you
heard gas tax those two are go together
the turnpike tools are not the same as
the road toll and and that gets
confusing sometimes for people you might
hear about the rainy day fund well
that's also considered the revenue
stabilization fund so I just tried to
highlight a few um
few acronyms or abbreviations you might
hear through your process here you'll
hear about House Bill 2 uh Liquor
Commission provided some language that
they're going to ask be included in
House Bill too House Bill 2 is
considered the trailer bill of the
operating budget so the operating budget
is House Bill one typically and that's
the numbers and the revenue unrestricted
Revenue estimates will go into that if
there's legislative changes that need to
occur changes in statute that can't be
done in house bill one it needs to be
done in this trailer Bill and so that
gets introduced when the governor comes
forward he'll introduce both versions as
well as the capital budget and then um
you guys will be off and running
um page two
is just to give you a here's the tax
rates as they are at this moment and I
did put in where some are changing or
have just changed and then to give you
the split of where they might go so the
business profits tax
um the rate just went down to 7.5
for a periods ending on or after 12 31
23 and you can see that six percent of
that collected will go into the general
fund 1.5 percent of that collected will
go into the education trust fund and
that's statutorily set and there's some
splits there that you'll see
and I'm just going to keep kind of
chugging along because I know it's
snowing out and people may be looking
out the window go to page four
this is a document that our office has
prepared for this committee for a number
of years
um
well over 10 years and what we do here
is we try to take all the information
you're getting as it relates to
unrestricted revenue and the
unrestricted Revenue that you're dealing
with is general fund education trust
fund Highway fund and Fish and Game fund
so those are the four areas that you'll
be addressing you've heard uh mention of
the turnpike fund as a restricted fund
there's a number of funds that have
already been designated for a purpose by
the legislature over the years and those
would be budgeted for those purposes and
they'd be dealt with in the operating
budget but you don't have to set the
revenue estimates for those
so if you flip the page six
dra will come in right now we're they're
coming in on the seventh to do kind of a
high level presentation to you they're
not going to give you numbers at that
point it's just going to be to explain
the tax and how they would do their
estimates they're going to come back on
the 22nd and provide you their revenue
estimate ranges for the various taxes
that they collect
what I end up doing is putting it in a
page like this and I'll give you the
high low range that they give you for
the year
so the current year we're in would be
2023 and then they have some growth
percentages that they might apply and
then I'll put those in the low high
going to the 22 and 23 or 24 25.
then when you flip the page to page
seven
you're going to see the current fiscal
year that just completed so fiscal year
22 and so in this case it's because it's
last Cycles you're going to see fiscal
year 20 but you would see 22 23 24 and
25.
22 would show you what the official plan
was and then what the year closed out at
so you get a sense of that page I
suggested you look at in the act for
just before lunch that would be carried
forward here so you could see that and
see the difference and then on 20 for
fiscal year 22 3 we would load in what
the revenue plan is that was developed
after the last operating budget and then
we'd give you the governor's estimate so
the governor is going to be coming out
with his operating budget which would
include revenues on Valentine's Day
February 14th I believe he's going to be
presenting to the house and the Senate
um and so that at that point that
information would be public and we'd
have that information to load into this
document
um
and then we wouldn't we start to
incorporate the Agency information that
you've been hearing today and then you
will hear as you go forward and we put
it high in a low mainly for the dra
estimates because most agencies just
give you a single number as you've seen
today they don't give you a high low as
to what they think they're projecting
when we do this document I keep
everything combined at I don't split out
the General on the education trust fund
I keep it combined as you're doing your
estimates and then after you're done
with your estimates we'll split out
we'll do the splits to show how much is
general fund how much is education trust
fund but if you look at the top of the
columns you know a b c you'll see
General gen and ETF that just means that
that Revenue Source goes to both those
funds
you'll see that liquor transfer is just
to the general fund
you do this we do the same thing to the
highway fund if you go to page 11
. and for the highway fund you only have
three Revenue sources essentially
you have the road toll you have the
motor vehicles which is the and then the
miscellaneous the miscellaneous is what
you just heard from dot so all the the
page that you you saw from safety that
listed out all the different Revenue
sources I roll that up to give you these
numbers as you see here and under each
of those categories
fishing game again the same thing
so so that's the working document that
I'll be producing for this committee as
you go through the process so you have a
meeting you've made some suggested
suggestions on what you think the
estimate should be I would put populate
the document re
um send it to you so you'd have it come
to the next meeting with hard copies and
go through that whole process
you'll get to a point where this
committee will say
we agree that these are the numbers and
you vote that these are unrestricted
revenues that we want to present
at that point what we've done is we've
worked to get a house resolution so if
you turn to page 14
you'll see last time it was house
resolution number 11 the chair of the
committee is the sponsor
and if you flip to page 15
basically we restate the current fiscal
year we're in we'll give you what the
official plan was and then if this
committee has made adjustments to that
so if you say
um the business tax revenue is going to
be 25 million dollars higher than what
the existing plan is that would be what
would be the committee estimate and so
that would show up in this
and then whatever the estimates would be
for 24 and 25. so the official plan
which gets um presented at the end of
the operating budget doesn't change
throughout the process administrative
Services takes the information and does
the all their work from the existing
Revenue plan and I'll get to that in
just a second
so this house resolution is typically
offered to the full body to to consider
and then after the discussion is had
with that in the past the committee the
house has tabled this resolution so you
you vote on it and then you table it and
just let it sit there
from that
I provide the finance committee with
your unrestricted revenues that will end
up in the back of house bill one
so if you turn to page 18 that's the
start of what would be considered House
Bill one house bill one again is the all
the numbers
at the back of house bill one there's
what we call sections back of the budget
sections they so Pages 19
through 24 are what we call back of the
budget section so there's some budget
notes there's some can language related
to Lottery and then there may be some
additional Appropriations for agencies
there should not be any RSA restrictions
or changes here it's just how they can
use money that's been appropriated
but you get to page 23
those would be your unrestricted Revenue
estimates
your Revenue estimates are based on
current law
so you this committee May deal with a
bill you may agree on a bill and pass it
out of here it may pass the Full House
your Revenue estimates don't change here
we track that on what we call the
Surplus statement and I'll show you that
in just a moment as well
and if anybody has any questions please
stop me
yep
back on page 15 and 16.
the the column that says 2021 on here is
going to say 2023. correct so
are we involved with that yes so okay
yep so so what this committee is doing
is that because it's been almost 18
months since the revenue plans have been
set
thing you have a better view of what's
going on we know that Revenue was about
400 million dollars ahead of projections
last year you're seeing some trending
this year where revenue is already over
200 million dollars ahead of plan is
that going going to continue or not
there'll be some discussions in this
committee based on what you've heard
um from the various presentations
earlier what you're going to hear from
the agencies going forward and you'll
make some decisions about what you
believe where you believe the revenues
will end for fiscal year 23 which may be
different than what the official plan
was
the column that says official estimate
is was that is that the original
estimate yes okay yep
yep
everybody's all set I'll continue on
um if you go to page 25 that's the start
of um
the general fund education trust fund
Surplus statement so our office will
manage this through the finance with the
finance division as they're making
decisions
um
so as I started to say your Revenue
estimates are on current law but if a
bill were to pass the full body were to
adopt that had an impact on your Revenue
we would make an adjustment on the um
Surplus statement so if you turn to page
it's going to be schedule two at the top
of it
and you'll see Row one says Revenue
adjustments excuse me Revenue
adjustments and then rows
basically 2 through 13 are all
adjustments that occurred throughout the
budget building process
now you're going to see what the
governor had you're going to see what
the house does you'll be able to see
what the Senate does and then when it
gets time to committee a conference
you'll know what they did at that point
we also do the same thing obviously for
anything that impacts the expenditure
side of the equation too and that's the
bottom half of the page going on to the
next page
rips and games
just want to point out and you can
confirm this that this is an active
document that you keep posted up to date
as you're going through a process that
not all of us are privy to because it
just can't be that way you know so
decisions are made there's an adjustment
that needs to be made it reaches that
point in this Surplus statement then the
end of the day or whenever
lbao will be updating what's posted
there isn't that is that correct so we
WE Post all the Surplus statement would
be at the end that we'll start with one
I think Mike talked about doing a
snapshot when it comes time
and that's basically just taking where
we're at today at this moment then we'll
start building the Surplus statement
based on what the governor has done and
then as finance committee starts to make
decisions
there'll be some adjustments but also as
the committee start to pass bills so if
your committee not your committee but if
a committee passes a bill that say has
appropriation in it and the full body
adopts that we would carry it on this
Surplus statement
so that you have the what we would call
the house position
so that you you know this is what we as
the body had supported and that that
becomes important when you get to the
committee conference time so you know
what your positions were so you if you
want to negotiate with the Senate they
know what their positions were and you
can come to some hopefully some
consensus that works and gets a an
agreed upon final product
um
so at the end of the finance phase there
would be an updated Surplus statement at
the end of the Senate Finance stage that
would be an updated Surplus statement
um
yet when the Full House or full Senate
votes on it if there was any changes to
the
um the budget bills at that time if
there was an amendment adopted and it
needed to update the Surplus we would do
that as well it'll all be on our website
but you're correct in building the
document it's not like we show it every
day like oh here's a new line because
something's come on and off
um the best laid plans you know that you
think a commit the body might adopt
something and then they don't you know
maybe an item gets tabled
um you know the all indication was it
was going to pass but in the end they
decide the table it
so we don't include that because it's
not I'm active at that moment
representative
I'm just so I understand I'm reading
this right
um
so all of these numbers are like
Governor house senate committee of
conference the numbers are either adding
or subtracting to the appropriation
right to the the the top Revenue number
like for instance
uh yeah number 29.
20 yep so if you see brackets it's a
negative if you see no bracket it's a
positive so row row two is in 500 000
and then
um 2.1 million and 23 of additional
Revenue that would be expected to be
generated as a result of adding these
Auditors okay
um row four
was a decrease in the meals tax yep so
so we're taking that out taking that out
I see so we get Governor house senate
yep the committee of conference and
that's all right and then we end up with
the final number because as as you've
heard and probably are aware you need a
balanced budget by the time you're done
so we account for all that stuff that
occurs we put it in the wash and and
hopefully it comes out with a balance
with some sort of a surplus so that you
have a little bit of wiggle room
representative fellows
so so the what we're just looking at now
the one that's on page 29 that doesn't
this doesn't really appear until after
what point does this schedule appear so
you'll see it at the end of the fine
house finance phase that's when it will
come out because it's a living document
that will be added and subtracted to
um but just keep in mind that
you'll know what bills are being passed
what Appropriations essentially because
you'll see them on the floor you'll know
what this committee did with revenues
so if you did if you pass a bill that's
going to increase or decrease your
revenues we'll carry that on the Surplus
statement typically we use what the
agencies projected as the impact so it
it could it's the best number that we
have in some instances and like for Dra
we talk a lot about static analysis so
it's not a dynamic analysis so you may
not be able to
um
you know see the true impact because you
don't know what the behavior of the
taxpayer might be now I say that there
may be also Direction provided by
leadership that says you know we think
the estimate by the agency's too high or
low we want you to carry this number on
the Surplus statement
so that's what we would do
but for the most part you should be able
to find it a reason for the number
that's there and and we'll be able to
help you with that if you have any
questions
keep going
so the
we'll keep flipping we do the same thing
for a highway that's on page 34. it's
much smaller
and then 35 is the fish and game Surplus
statements
um page 36 is now the what we call the
official Revenue
um monthly Revenue plan
so once the legislature finishes its
process
and the governor has signed the bill or
let it become law without his signature
Department of administrative services
will work with the agencies that
generate this revenue and come up with a
monthly plan
how much are we going to get each month
in these areas
understand it's an estimate and
sometimes it you'll see more or less
than a month
um there's reasons often for that
sometimes it can be explained sometimes
they can't easily be explained because
um if it's a business or a tax at dra
collects and maybe there's a single
entity that's causing that month to
curve upwards or downwards then they
can't tell us that they've got to keep
that quiet
but what you do get at the end of every
month is on page 40
is the monthly Revenue Focus again this
is a document produced by administrative
Services I think this is probably
any you're probably getting daily
revenue emails from myself from
administrative services and from dra
I would suggest that they're not overly
important you don't need to read them
every day
um you can
ignore them for the most part um but you
know I think I think some of the dra
ones can be kind of interesting but more
so they're end of month ones
the revenue focus is what you really
should be looking at that comes out
usually
three business days after the close of
the month approximately
the first page of that will tell you did
you make plan or not make plan for the
four unrestricted Revenue sources that's
the Box on the up upper left corner
right underneath that is the current
month for your general education trust
fund so it'll show you what the actual
amount collected for the month and then
what the plan was for that month and if
you're up or down
and then on the right hand side is the
analysis and they'll hit several of the
taxes and give you a kind of a little
blurb as to what occurred in that month
with these taxes
you flip the page
you're going to see a number of smaller
boxes
the first one is the real estate
transfer tax that just gives you a sense
of how that's comparing to previous
fiscal years and percentage changes
the one below that is the meals and
rooms analysis that's a fairly new box
and that's coming in as a result of the
Restriction of
meals and rooms Revenue into the
municipal Revenue fund so that's that 30
percent of meals and rooms that goes
back to the communities it used to not
be in a restricted fund it just used to
be an appropriation
so this is just showing you basically
um
what the collections were for the month
how much went out to school building Aid
Debt Service so back in 2009 10 and 11
building Aid was bonded and this is the
the law at that time said they needed to
use meals and rooms Revenue to pay back
those bonds and that just shows you the
the amount for the month that went out
for that purpose and then underneath
that is the new Municipal Revenue
transfer
and then you get a netting effect of
what when it's going to go into the
unrestricted meals and rooms
the next is the tax refunds the business
tax refunds so refunds are uh I should
have actually let me just back up for a
second everything you're doing is on a
cash basis so money in Money out
when dra needs to pay a refund that's
cash they're paying back out so if you
don't collect enough it could show as a
negative and when you're looking at some
of the daily revenues there's on
occasion you might see a negative
because they had a refund and then the
next day it's a positive it's because
they booked more Revenue
um and it made it into the system
so it's just kind of it gives you a
sense of what goes on they give you a
um the end at the end of month reports
they have a page that talks about their
rev refunds and they also have to submit
to fiscal committee on a quarterly basis
uh Revenue refund report
then the next on the bottom of page 41
is just a comparison to the previous
year
right
it's okay I guess it's information but
really I think page 42 is
um
the year-to-date comparison so that'll
tell you right through the end of this
through December this is how much you've
collected
this is how much you had planned for
and you and it tells you by um
general fund and education trust fund so
you can see the split on that so you can
see through December
you had a hundred and almost 155 million
dollars of general fund
ahead of the plan
you have a 52 just over 52 million
dollars of Education trust fund over
plan collected so far this year
when you get the
um daily report from the Department of
administrative Services if you do get
that you're going to see a chart that
looks just like this in the report and
then there's one that's for the month to
date
What You Won't See is the split to the
education trust fund you'll see negative
numbers to start don't panic
they don't do the splits until the close
of the business month and the reason for
that is that the revenue is coming in
change and it adjusted almost every day
so if they were trying to do the
education trust fund splits they'd be
correcting those every day so they just
wait to the end of the month and say
okay we're done collections now we'll do
the split and put it in the right bucket
I I do get a number of calls on that you
know oh it shows like we don't have
enough money in the education trust fund
we're not collecting what we need in
fact you are
I think it's also important to note just
with the education trust fund
um that that is a non-lapsing fund so at
the end of the biennium that money does
not lapse back into the revenue
stabilization fund it stays in the
education trust fund unlike the general
fund if you have any excess general fund
it will be put into the rainy day fund
up to a certain point and if you reach
that threshold it's about 400 million
right now if you reach that threshold
then anything above that would just stay
as a bounce forward
representative Army did you have a
question
and
Phil Sutton told us that the split is
more like 70 instead of 60 now
business profits taxes BT
so they all they all are putting it that
way
so they the department of administrative
Services works with dra to do the splits
so they they try to
they try to get the split as close as
they can and that's why sometimes you
might see some numbers are running a
little bit negative maybe it didn't get
quite right again it's assumptions are
being made on how the revenue is coming
in but dra was running it was I think
like mid 60 percent so that it was like
35 65 was the split before we've always
heard 60 40 and you may hear that again
in this committee when they come through
because it does change every year
um
but just know that at the end of the
year money's poured into the right place
that it needs to be so even though we
talk about a 60 40 split that's not a
binding split
the law is what tells you how to split
those funds
so the law directs how much goes the
education trust fund in terms of a
percentage and how much should go to the
general fund
representative yeah follow up on so we
don't really know how much went to bet
versus BPT until look after comes out
or for some of you in August well you'll
see so when you look at December right
now you can see
you know this is the cash basis what
they know now the official audit might
make some adjustment but
it hasn't been huge you might move a
million or two one way or the other it's
not like you're seeing you know 50
million get bumped into one place when
it should have been in the other
so I think
they do a pretty good job and so when
you're looking at this you you can see
that um
you know you're staying within your plan
for the most part of your splits
for under the education trust fund but
under your business Enterprise fund you
can see what we're running behind on
some of that collection
and again it's just the nature of that
split more of it goes of the BET goes to
the education trust fund than to the
general fund now
um
one thing to also keep in mind is
tobacco tax
um
so they tax cigarettes
and um everything over a dollar goes to
the education trust fund and everything
be Beyond below that goes to the general
fund except for the um
other tobacco products so those just go
to the general fund and two cycles ago
we added The Vaping
e-cigarette things and I may be using
the wrong terms
um and that's increased the revenue
that's coming in but that Revenue all
goes to the general fund so when I did
the splits last time I didn't I didn't
know and didn't even consider that
it was only about one to two percent of
the OTP that was going to the general
fund so it didn't really impact the
split now it's up for closer to ten
percent so that's something to keep in
mind when I do the splits to make sure I
get it correct but that didn't keep the
department of administrative services
from putting it in the right bucket
and then the last page of the revenue
focus is just some Highway fun fishing
game fun information and a little bit on
liquor analysis
um and the reason for the liquor box on
the bottom it goes back to what they
talked about the transfer to the
governor's Commission on alcohol and
drug
or substance use and then the transfer
the granite advantage
the transfer to granted Advantage is
something that's new
three sessions ago
and basically the commissioner has to do
an analysis every six months of that
fund and put puts out information to the
finance committee to
um
commissioner dra I think you know
there's a whole slew of places that get
this letter that says we may need to
transfer some money from Liquor
Commission and we'll give a number and
the reason that you're seeing these
transfers is um
the Medicaid roles have increased well
during covid and right now you may have
heard some discussion about people who
are on Medicaid they don't have to get
um
reauthorized every year you just stay on
the roll because the concern that people
would fall off because it's kind of a
complex process to go through every year
while we're in the public health
emergency
once the public health emergency ends or
I believe there's a some
at the federal level there's some
language I guess that that would
have a hard end to this this uh Medicaid
staying on the rules in the end of March
I believe
um but you may see this may see some of
these people come off and you may see
less money needing to be transferred as
a result of that from The Liquor
Commission but that's something we'll
have to wait and see that is something
that keep in the back of your minds when
Health and Human Services comes in on
the seventh that you may want to ask
some questions about
um Medicaid and the transfer from liquor
page 44 just kind of give you a a brief
the tax you're seeing what does it
represent
your meals and rooms taxed that you see
collected this month reflects activity
last month
so it's not what's happening today it's
what happened last month
your insurance tax that's just the
collection that they're doing today for
the year you know so that
so it's really more just to let you know
that there's some taxes that they're a
month behind so you want to know that
when you're looking at oh this is really
good Revenue it's because we had a
really good month it was warm people
were traveling they were spending a lot
of money in tourism in New Hampshire
the next the month we're in is rainy and
and it's um you know the colder maybe
people aren't doing as much outdoors and
travel you might see a slight dip in
that but
representative almond thank you but in
fact business profits business
Enterprise interests and dividends uh
well a fair number of them actually do
not reflect economic activity that
happens now they reflect it from oh it's
prior year two to three years ago that's
just coming in through the tax return
this month
this page was more to alert you to when
sometimes there's confusion when you're
looking at meals and rooms or you're
looking at Lottery and you're like oh
geez we got a big bump up in Lottery but
you have to remember it was the previous
month oh and there was a huge Powerball
and so they collected a lot of Revenue
as it relates to that
representative fellows so you're talking
about when we look
uh page 44.
look at page 40 or are you saying that
on on 44 does it say that this report
that says December at the top is only
Revenue through the end of November
that's Revenue that was collected and
put in the books in December but it may
be the result of activity from the
previous month so meals and rooms is
based on what you collected in November
they deposited in December
right right they don't have to they get
they get to the 15th of the month to
send their payments in
and then the last group of pages uh 45
through
62 or just
RSA references to the various Revenue
sources that you're dealing with and
what
two things that I put in it's not the
entire statute for any of these Revenue
sources it's the piece of the tax that
says here's the tax rate you're to
charge
and then here's where the revenues to go
so you look on page 46 for example
it's the business profits tax RSA 77 A2
colon 2
tells you the tax rate that's to be in
effect and for what period
77-a colon 20 Dash small a tells you
where those funds are to go
that 1.5 percent
of whatever is collected
will go to the education trust fund and
the rest of it will go to the general
fund
everything goes to the general fund
unless it's there's a law that tells it
to go somewhere else
so that's all I had I'm not going to go
through every page of that it's just
more of a reference
um
you may want you may find the shoes
useful you may not find it useful it's
more just to put the thoughts in your
head
um but as you go through the process any
questions again reach out to me you see
me in the room ask me a question you
need me to Chase something for you I can
do that
by no means am I the expert the agencies
that come in that collect these revenues
are the experts they're the ones that
know some of the trends and stuff but I
I will happily reach out to them and get
information for the committee as it
needs it
represent Rochford I just had a question
representative Almy got me thinking
about something here with like the
business profits tax
so in my experience paying that in the
bet I paid it quarterly yep you do an
estimate so it and she brings up a good
point in that I just paid my bet tax the
other day
for business that was a year ago
estimating what's happening this year so
um
that being said it's a quarterly it's a
quarterly payment
but if we're estimate and I guess it
doesn't matter if we're going to come up
with just a big overall number that we
give to the appropriation and tell them
this is what your the number is but I
mean looking at these
how can we plan on a monthly Revenue if
it's a something we generally collect
quarterly and I understand at the end of
the year it doesn't matter but
I mean we really won't we won't have I
mean November you probably don't have a
lot of bet or BPT coming in but December
you probably do so what the department
does Department of Revenue will do is
work with administrative services to set
a plan and they have a sense of
um
how much revenue is coming in based on
history
so they'll use percentages to kind of
figure that out and they'll know that
you know um you know the first half of
the year and I'm just going to make up
numbers you collect 35 percent of your
BPT
you get 70 in the second half of the
year with most of that being in April
would so so they'll devise the plan to
reflect some of that so you'll see
no no you're you're just dealing with
the higher numbers what you're going to
do is debate you know based on what
we're hearing and what my experiences
are I think it should be at 900 million
and somebody else is going to say it
should be at 9.50 and then you'll have
your anecdotal reasons for suggesting
why you said 900 versus 950 and then
this committee will come to some some
sort of agreement
um so a lot oh
representative Ames yeah I just wanted
to
add to this point that it's
we really operate with
scant information
um and uh we're dealing with return
information that dra has that reflects
economic activity some time ago so the
estimates may be really just based on it
what was paid the previous year and not
not even represent a judgment by the
particular business that's making the
estimate that things are going sour or
going great so we're left puzzling
through this thing and it's really hard
so so the last comment I'll make is
um rip some Sanborn and I have been
working on trying to schedule
um the agencies so on February 7th the
agencies that were due to see you on
Monday will be coming in in addition to
we'll start with um doj to talk about
the tobacco settlement and then we'll go
into dra they'll have about an hour and
a half and they're going to talk to you
just about the taxes they collect and
how they would do estimates related to
those you'll get some of that
information about timing I believe as
well
um then in the afternoon we're going to
have Department of administrative
Services come in along with the treasury
Department and they're going to talk
about the revenue the act for the
revenue plan and other Revenue so that's
what there's about 200 sources of what's
categorized as other Revenue
with about 15 of them being major
players in that category
abandoned property is one of those which
is dealt with by the treasury Department
so that's why the treasurer is going to
be here within that same hour and then
when they finish the presentation on the
other Revenue she'll spin into
discussing some um
some of the cash flow I mean I think she
started this at the economic briefing
um but she didn't get through everything
so she's going to kind of get through
what her department does and then just
some of the cash flow and what they do
with money sitting in treasury you know
what what do they do with that and then
after Treasury
at two o'clock will be Health and Human
Services and then at 2 30 fishing game
that's going to be February 7th and I'll
send a schedule out to the committee I'm
using the group email on the Committee
website and I'll and I'll send that to
you and I won't send it right away
um because I don't want it to get lost
and then on the 22nd um I think will be
the first day that you're going to
really dive into trying to do some of
your estimates
so that we've asked the governor's
budget director to come and talk to you
about what they did and why they're
coming up with their estimates I got
confirmation from him that he can come
that'll be at 10 o'clock at 10 30 dra
will come in again to talk with you
until about noonish with some of their
revenue sources and at that point
they'll be talking to you about their
projections or their estimates and the
ranges that they have
um and then in the afternoon I've got a
I suspect you probably want um Lottery
to come back in the afternoon and then
whoever else you guys may want
so it's still open
um
I think after you hear the presentations
on the seventh
I would suggest if there's certain
agencies you think need to come back we
can schedule them in on in the 22nd and
I think let the chair or myself know and
we can coordinate that
and that's what we've got at the moment
and anybody have any questions if not
I'm all done
and the snow stopped
great job thank you for everything you
do for us we cannot do this without him
so thank you
but folks again don't get overwhelmed
um we're keeping it at a high level we
are not going to try to figure out which
month and when no let's keep it high
level do we think we're growing in this
area or not and why how much are we
growing
okay